All right.
We are live on youtube people.
I have just returned from touring with Jordan Peterson.
I went directly to Joe Rogan and now we're going to do a show.
Joining me today is neuroscientists,
bestselling author and mysterious man of Internet controversy,
Sam Harris.
Welcome back to the Ruben.
How was that for an intro for you?
Mysterious man of Internet works as well as anything else in my bio.
Yeah.
You seem to be somebody that wants inner peace and yet constantly involved in
these endless I to enough to screw that up.
It seems for,
for reasons that I can't figure out,
but is that a scientific test for you?
Possibly.
Well,
you know,
I've just,
uh,
I don't think we've talked about this,
but I have pulled back from social media to a big degree and that,
that is a variable that,
I mean,
I obviously,
I,
I'd heard that advertised to me as a problem and I had thought about it in the
abstract as a problem.
And I know you've gone off the grid for a month or something,
but just,
I mean,
I,
I've cut down,
I was never using Facebook as anything other than a publishing channel.
I never got into comments on Facebook,
but I got hooked by Twitter as you know,
and I'm probably spending five minutes a day on Twitter at most.
So aside from just,
it's just a surgical strike on Twitter,
just put something out and see what's there,
read a couple articles,
you know,
just find links to articles that interest me.
So,
I mean,
it's still a way of getting news,
but to not,
to fundamentally,
not only not engage,
but not even know what's going on on Twitter has been a total reset of my brain.
I mean it's,
it's,
um,
it's been amazingly toxic in a way that I never appreciate it.
Yeah.
So I think my audience knows my feelings on this steady.
It's endlessly toxic.
Yet at some level it's helped connect all of us.
I mean,
we originally connected through Twitter.
These things kind of morph and change and have moments where they're much worse
and then suddenly they're much better.
They also help,
you know,
help start revolutions in the Middle East.
So it's like not all evil,
but are you afraid?
A little bit of getting disconnected all,
all together that you'll miss some of the Zeitgeists
I'm definitely missing stuff.
Yeah.
And I'm,
uh,
I'm still trying to use it strategically,
so I'm trying to use it in precisely the way you just described what they're
trying to get connected with people.
I reached out to somebody who's this woman dia,
who just did a documentary.
I want to get her on the podcast.
I tweeted at her,
uh,
I haven't spent enough time looking to see if she's even noticed.
So it's like I'm not totally paying attention,
but the benefit has been just immense because I just realized I,
there's a kind of,
it's a kind of hallucination machine where you begin to think you need to pay
attention to certain voices that in the real world you would never see.
And they,
and I'm agnostic as to whether or not these voices are in fact consequential and
that you could sort of lose sight of how your reputation's unraveling online and
you know,
just start getting phone from friends saying,
sorry that's happening to you.
Which I think is,
you know,
that's happened to some people.
But yeah.
Um,
you know,
in my experience,
I,
maybe there's some exception to this,
but virtually all of my kind of substantial controversial engagements on Twitter
where I've noticed somebody go after me and then I've responded and then I
either have done a podcast in [inaudible],
whatever the,
the,
uh,
however that's propagated in my life.
The net result has always been like,
you're getting back to zero if you're lucky.
Right.
It's like the whole thing is a confection of having been on social media in the
first place and you're lucky to get back to zero.
And,
uh,
I mean,
the truth is someone like me,
we can name the,
you know,
the usual [inaudible] afternoon,
let me,
none of these people exist in the real world.
I know,
like,
I mean,
they're not,
it's,
you know,
and I would never see them just reading the New York Times for the most part.
Um,
I certainly never see them in my life and it's just,
it's very strange to feel like because someone had said something about you on
social media or,
or,
you know,
lied about you or spread an article that was terrible about your,
whatever it is that you then have to somehow engage and,
and people,
you know,
right?
Like,
you know,
who was it?
Uh,
or most recently,
Robert Wright just wrote this idiotic wired piece about me.
Right?
It's just like there's,
there's not a single sentence in the piece that needs to be responded to.
And I get inundated with by people think,
well,
this is,
you really got to respond to this.
This is,
this is interesting and substantial and it's nothing of the kind.
It's like it's his attempted clickbait.
It's his attempt to provoke a,
some kind of controversy between us on one of our podcasts.
I mean,
he reached out to me,
so I just wrote this about you,
you know,
I hope you'll come on my podcast or I'll come on yours to talking about
efficient.
Yeah.
And it's just,
it's a completely disingenuous and insubstantial thing and yet paying attention,
it is a kind of meditation.
It's like,
it's,
you have to become what you meditate on,
you become what you pay attention to.
And so checking Twitter 30 times a day or whatever I was doing,
just built a new mind for me,
which I,
you know,
I,
I'm very happy to get rid of.
So,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know that I'll ever get totally off it because for the reasons you
suggest,
but I,
I've cut it down literally by 95%.
Yeah.
So I saw the interview you did was that CBS news about a week or two ago and you
talked about how it's kind of making us all crazy.
I know that was an Australian,
that was that Australia that was there was,
there was ABC in Australia.
So I saw that and you said something about how it's kind of making us all crazy
and he was making me think too,
to your point,
just now that it seems like we're almost living in two worlds at the same time
right now.
Like if you walk around staring at that thing,
like I'm traveling with that now.
So if I'm like at the airport,
like I'm looking at this thing,
you always get disconnected from the actual physical location.
Oh yeah,
you totally do.
You start ending up in some alternate world and to me that's a little bit sort
of where we're going to end up with with Ai,
with all of these,
they're all gonna kind of collide
into one thing that we're going to end up in the matrix or something like that.
Yeah.
Well and you can be buried on your phone obviously without being buried on
social media.
So,
you know,
I've,
I've taken it off my phone,
which is a huge yeah.
Um,
kind of gatekeeping function.
But
uh,
what do you think about how it changes our perception of time?
Because that's actually where I was going to start with you cause we just
figured out,
so the last time you were on the show was July of 2016 basically two years ago,
which is crazy and it sort of seems like yesterday to me and yet it also seems
like like 18 lifetimes ago and I think that maybe has something to do with
social media changing the way we perceive time or something.
Uh,
well,
I don't know.
I don't think it's just social media.
I think it's just,
it's everything.
Everything is conspiring to make time go faster as you're getting older.
Just the,
the,
the increase in novelty and just cha interested.
But we have,
we're seeing changes in culture and technology that are clearly accelerating so
that the world is different over the course of more different over the course of
the year.
Then it's ever been,
I think that's,
that's subjectively true.
But also you're just getting older so that every year is,
you know,
that much less a piece of your,
the,
the life you've lived,
you know,
if you're,
if you're 40,
you know,
the next years is one 40th of the time you've been around and then you know,
that becomes one 50th and so it's subjectively shorter and uh,
yeah,
I'm a year for me it's like four months long now.
Just,
yeah,
they just blast by.
So there are a couple of things I want to hit on here.
We'll do a little bit of politics,
but I do want to talk about uh,
consciousness and I want to talk about your upcoming talks with Peterson and
obviously I've gotten to know his mind pretty well at this point.
Have some inside information that I should have at this point.
I might,
I might be able to offer you a little something and,
and I think maybe we can set the table for how many events are you doing with
them?
We're doing four.
We have four.
The only four we've spoken about others,
but I think four is certainly enough to see whether we can,
we can do this.
So the funny thing,
it might be three,
two minutes.
That's what I'm worried.
It might be forging metal you'll find out.
But the funny thing is that I didn't know until I mentioned to him last night
when we were at Atlanta,
I said,
oh,
you know,
I have Sam on tomorrow.
Um,
is there anything on your mind that I can bring up that'll sort of set the table
for this whole thing?
I didn't realize that you guys have actually never met in person,
which having listened to the two podcasts,
which you did on a computer,
on Skype or whatever,
that that podcasting thing you used,
that's kind of crazy that you guys haven't actually sat there and just,
you know,
looked in his eyes and I've done this.
Does that feel weird to you that you're going to do all this publicly in that
way?
Well,
I've done a bunch of events with people I've never met,
you know,
like words,
a podcast guest or someone I'm sharing the stage with for the first time.
And so I've actually,
I've,
I know him better than s s several of the people I've recently done live events
with in San Diego.
I've spoken to on the phone ones and we've done those two podcasts.
Yeah.
But yeah,
no,
it's,
I,
it's obviously not optimal to be having these conversations.
Uh,
a well,
it selects for different things.
I think there are people,
I think it's,
I think Terry Gross of fresh air will never do anything face to face.
I think she does all of her interviews.
Even if you're in Philadelphia,
I could,
could be radiology,
I'm getting this wrong.
I think she just likes to this sort of the purity of pure audio.
And it could,
because the product is audio,
there's no video component to it.
And I understand that in the sense that if you're having like,
so,
so if we were just doing an audio podcast now,
I mean now is it just a pure audio podcast or I'm sensitive to this.
You and I are having an experience now we're looking at each other.
We have various cues.
We,
we know we have a sense of how the conversation's going in and which,
which can be misleading you because if the final product is just audio,
you can think there's stuff coming through which isn't coming through.
And so when you don't have any of those,
any of that information and you just got the other person's voice on the line,
you have a very clear sense of what you're getting and if you're not getting
what you want to be getting and then you modify what you're doing in some,
on some level.
So,
yeah.
Um,
so yeah,
it's working for me,
but I think it's,
as far as establishing rapport with someone,
it's definitely not ideal.
So we,
we've had moments where we've,
we could have used more
or probably,
yeah.
Alright.
Let's shelve the rest of Peter's until,
after.
What,
what do you make of this whole thing?
Somehow the conversations that we've all been having often completely
independently of each other.
Right?
I mean,
you haven't been here for two years have suddenly become like the zeitgeists
thing.
Like you know,
Barry Weiss wrote this intellectual,
dark web article.
People think we have a card and there's a clubhouse and the whole thing as far
as if there is,
I haven't been invited,
but that whatever it is,
we're all doing the conversations you're having and I'm having and Rogan's
having,
and this whole crew of people seem to be doing something that was very needed at
some level or another.
Yeah.
Well I think there's certainly a diversity of opinion within this group or a
pseudo group about what's going on here.
I mean,
we,
as you know,
we have not had a meeting where we've agreed that,
you know,
what about what this is,
but it's anything.
We've had a quiet half a meeting where we disagreed on it,
barely that.
And did you see Eric Weinstein's video about just what,
what this was and that,
I mean,
it's like,
so 100% of what he said on that video was never anything that he said to me or
that,
you know,
it's like this,
this is how he coined the phrase in his own mind.
Well,
I had just brought him up on stage at,
in Tempe at the Improv the night before and I think he was high on comedy and
just like,
I'm going to talk to people.
So I found everything you said.
Very interesting.
And as you know,
I love Eric.
He's fantastic.
But,
uh,
here,
he coined the phrase on my podcast,
I think in an earlier podcast,
but then it was reiterated in this live event we did with Ben Shapiro,
you named.
And then I came
then that was with that podcast and I,
no exaggeration,
I thought for like 15 seconds,
but what I was going to title this podcast,
it was just,
you know,
so it,
it was,
has always been tongue in cheek and,
um,
if fairly superficial analogy for me and,
but,
but an interesting one in the sense that there is a,
the analogy to the dark web is appropriate in that
insofar as there's this area where a lot is going on,
that the mainstream media in this case is basically unaware of.
I mean,
obviously there's many people in the mainstream media and people who consume the
mainstream media where there are lists also listening to my podcast or Rogan's
are watching you.
Uh,
so you know,
many people know we exist,
but people,
uh,
are,
have been very slow to appreciate just how big the audiences,
I mean,
Rogan's audience is just an enormous,
you know,
and our audiences are absurd compared to what's happening on,
on CNN for instance.
But um,
you know,
I mean Rogan's audiences like it's like every episode is the finale of the game
of Thrones,
right?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's completely insane.
No one knows this,
right?
Like he,
I mean,
he carried occasionally brags about how big his audience is,
but it's,
my sense is that people,
the New York Times aren't aware or people,
even CNN aren't aware that they're in competition with me.
Just to take CNN is the most relevant column.
If you get invited to go on Anderson Cooper show tonight and give an interview,
you're going to get six minutes,
you know,
the best case,
12 minutes to try to make sense and try to not embarrass yourself with Ian.
I've within a frame that is really rigid.
It's not me.
It's the time pressure alone modifies you just what kind of conversations you
can have there.
And in prime time you're going to go out to a million people at best with
Anderson Cooper and how many are actually watching the television?
I mean the television's on in all sorts of applications that nobody's even
watching.
Yeah.
So I count my audience,
it's something like a million people and as hard as you know,
to get great podcast metrics,
but Joe's is probably 10 times that per episode if not more.
So.
I mean you're talking to so and,
and in those cases you're talking about two and three hour conversations that
people are actually listening to and forget about what it's like to be the host
on a show like that.
The,
the opportunity for someone else to come on and have a conversation and make
sense and correct themselves and go through the whole warp and woof of,
of of a,
a genuine conversation that isn't unnaturally bounded by a time limit.
I mean,
I noticed the difference between a an hour long radio conversation that gets
ported to the podcast where everyone just knew clearly that they had to bring
this in.
And an hour was like,
even that defines the conversation.
And so,
uh,
I think people are very slow to wake up to how those two things,
like a big audience with an unlimited time,
uh,
for,
for a conversation changes.
Uh,
and also just different,
you know,
incentives with respect to funding of these things because he knows there's no
one,
no one's going to fire Joe Rogan,
Sam Harris identifiers.
I have iris.
Yeah,
no,
not a well,
well I fired my,
uh,
my Twitter director,
but,
um,
it's,
and so that,
that part of the analogy is interesting because it's allowing for a very
different style of Erin ideas and the,
and the substance is changing,
you know?
And so,
uh,
and I think people value it and be you,
you,
you know,
when you're listening to one of our podcasts that you're getting a,
a much less paranoid,
much less circumspect,
much more,
uh,
open ended ser search for sanity and,
and,
you know,
got kind of convergence between,
in some cases,
radically different opinions.
Uh,
then you're getting in other media.
I like that open ended search for sanity because I think we've all tried to
figure out what are the commonalities here because right.
We've got,
I mean you invented basically disagree on every,
not only pretty much every political position,
not not everyone,
but probably 90% of the political stuff do you and Ben Shapiro.
Uh,
but of course also the existential stuff and religion and all that stuff.
And yet you guys are basically allies in that.
You're defending the ability to have that disagreement.
That seems to me to be the thing that we're all doing.
Like we,
we respect our audiences,
but more than that we're respecting the ability for people to sit here and
disagree about things.
And we have a couple of political disagreements that I want to get into a little
bit.
But to me those disagreements aren't even that important as long as we're
defending the ability to think and question.
And I think that's what we've all sort of done,
even though we all came at it from very different places.
Yeah.
And I think the master variable for me is a good faith disagreement.
So it's like,
it's where I like,
I'm actually concerned to get your position right.
And again,
some of this does,
I think boil down to not having a time limit too.
It's like I can take the time,
it doesn't matter if you're like,
you know,
with Peterson and I,
we can burn the first hour is understanding one another,
right?
Or even longer.
Let me be the first whole podcast.
And then we do another podcast,
which you,
so it's,
um,
it's whereas in any other format,
you just,
you,
you don't have the time to wonder whether or not your wrong about what you think
the other person just said.
And then you add to that,
the,
the kind of the cynical point scoring that is just politically motivated,
uh,
that is omnipresent.
And in the usual context,
you know,
it,
you just have people who are actually not having a conversation.
Just,
I'm going to say the thing that I think is going to make you look bad in the 45
seconds we have left.
That's the situation you're virtually always in on television.
And people feel it.
And it's just like,
no wonder we're not making progress.
Having conversations about hard topics.
Yeah.
Well I think we're making progress and we as a visitor,
as a species I do.
And say,
well yeah,
that reminds me.
Can you just quickly recap,
you mentioned something on your podcast a couple of weeks ago about how when
when Shapiro and Jordan were here that uh,
that Jordan sort of misrepresented a position,
your position sort of untruth and that Ben then subsequently on Twitter
misrepresents saying you contacted both of them and cleaned it all up and
everyone was good to go.
Can you just recap that real quick because I think,
yeah,
sort of also gets to the heart of this that yes,
they,
they both kind of admitted,
yeah,
we,
one thing was half joke and whatever we screwed up something,
but that we all cleaned it up.
You guys all cleaned it up and we're good.
And I think it's just important to reiterate.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
that's a point I made that point on my podcast to reiterate the difference
between the kinds of bad faith arguments I'm getting predominantly from the left
and what I'm getting from the right.
And I mean it was,
I was actually provoked by a question on an Ama I got,
which actually it was,
it was probably your hate mail.
You know,
I'm getting a,
some of them,
some of your hate mails.
Right.
Weird that I forward that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a,
yeah.
You mean like I'm getting enough,
I'm sure you've gotten some of mind in the past,
but someone was saying like,
why are you hanging out with all these right wing people?
And you seem to be able to have a congenial conversation with right wingers
like,
and then the people on the list of right wingers were you and Rogan and,
and that any more plausibly Ben Shapiro,
Jordan Peterson,
gay married pro choice against the death penalty and reforming the prison
system,
blah,
blah.
Right?
Yeah.
And wrote Rogan's Rogan's conservative Boehner paydays or don't,
don't go much further than that as well.
Uh,
but uh,
he hunts.
That's,
that's what damn I guess.
Uh,
but so I,
you know,
why can't you have the same kind of good faith meeting of the minds with someone
on the left and one like as recline or any of your other antagonists on the left
and Glenn Greenwald or Chris Hedges.
And the difference has been in my experience is that on the left I am virtually
always getting,
I mean,
just like 90% of the time at least I'm getting a,
an argument that I perceive to be in bad faith where it's just there you're,
the effort is to slime you with a view you don't hold or take the worst
conceivable interpretation of the view you hold and hold you to that.
Like,
I saw this thing,
you,
I heard this thing you said,
I can interpret it to make you look like a fascist maniac.
So and so now the burden is on you for forever to prove you're not a fascist
maniac.
Right?
Yeah.
Pause
you there for a second.
Is there any chance that you think these,
forget the nit specifics of the people,
but is there any chance you think that these people are
co like consciously good?
You know what I mean,
like that there that they really are just so deeply misunderstanding that this
isn't an intention of evil in some gay.
I mean,
I,
we could sort of do the postmortem on some of these,
but some I think are genuinely confused on think are truly sinister in their
level of dishonesty.
Mean personally,
I think it's more of the latter.
But yeah,
I mean,
I mean someone like Jank younger,
I think he's,
he knows what he's doing and he's,
yeah,
he's a,
he knows he's misleading his audience and you know,
it was just pure politics.
Uh,
and I would,
you know,
many people I could name or fall into that then I would agree with you.
But,
uh,
so,
and then,
then the thing that that is,
is totally toxic is what is when it's absolutely clear that someone has
misrepresented your view.
Right?
So like when Glenn Greenwald forwards to now in millions of people,
a segment of my podcast that has been re edited by some Twitter troll to make me
seem to be saying the opposite of what I'm saying.
In fact,
in the,
in context,
he,
he'll never correct that error.
He'll,
and he'll never apologize.
Whereas I,
you know,
we'll,
we'll apologize instantly if I've misrepresented him.
Um,
the one time I did that,
you did it.
Yeah.
I mean,
you actually did do it.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
there's just as asymmetric warfare,
and so the point I made about Peterson and Shapiro,
there's so they both came on your show and in one way or another,
totally misrepresented my views may soap.
So Peterson quite comically in my world said,
you know,
the,
the thing about Sam Harrison,
he doesn't understand that consciousness is mysterious.
He doesn't,
he doesn't value [inaudible].
He went on this whole tirade about Mike not getting just how mysterious and
profound and,
and,
um,
uh,
interesting consciousness is.
Whereas anyone who knows my stuff knows that that's like the absolute center of
the center of the Bullseye for me,
ethically and intellectually.
Uh,
both as you know,
in terms of neuroscience and philosophy of mind,
moral philosophy.
I mean that's just,
you know,
I've,
I say things like consciousness is the one thing in this universe that can't be
an illusion.
Right?
I mean,
we could be in a simulation,
we could be brains and vads we could be confused about everything.
The one thing we can't be confused about is that,
you know,
consciousness is,
is our first,
you know,
condition in each instant.
Um,
so,
so I just emailed him and I said like,
Dude,
you've got me completely wrong on consciousness so you can get good cause you
have to stop saying what you just said on Reuben's podcast because a,
it makes no sense.
And rather than,
and this again,
if,
if I were going out to someone on the left,
you know,
the Ezra Klein's,
the raise os lawns,
the Genx,
the Chris hedges that Glenn Greenwald's,
um,
I like I was giving you the got to name via knows,
but I mean I've been down this path so many times with these guys.
I mean,
so the people think this all plays out in public and sometimes plays out in
private without every one of these guys.
There's been a private communication,
which is like,
listen,
this is objectively mistaken,
right?
Oh,
um,
never have gotten an apology or a correction about anything.
Right.
And what you get is basically fuck you.
This is what you really think.
You know,
you,
you know,
and um,
but with Jordan knows,
sorry,
I guess I have to read your book so I know what I'm talking about.
I said,
I think that's verbatim.
And by the way,
he has now,
he told me,
he told me last night,
so where he's read all your books,
little sees he's ready.
I'm sure he's still confused about something and those quotes.
But we'll work that out on stage.
But um,
and the same with Ben.
Ben was saying something about,
um,
I think,
I think it was free.
We'll joke right was right.
It was the joke about the kid.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I had at our event,
we got a question from the audience,
which,
uh,
where someone asks,
well,
so if free will is an illusion,
you know,
what should I tell my kids about free will?
Like,
do you lie to your kids or do you,
uh,
and I,
I made,
I,
I joke,
I said lie to them right.
At which given the fact that I've written a book about lying and,
and my,
I've taken a very public position that basically you never lie,
you don't even tell white lies,
lions on the continuum of violence and you just lie in,
in real extremis,
uh,
and it got to be left by,
they got got loud back there.
Everyone in the room recognize,
everyone knew that I would,
my audience knew I was joking,
but then didn't know I was joking.
Right.
So Ben,
what left and did some subsequent interviews saying,
well,
you know,
Sam Harris is remedy for this,
is that you just,
you know,
he thinks free will is an illusion,
but you know,
you should lie to your kids about it.
Right.
So I said,
Ben,
that was a joke and you know,
he is,
if he can certainly suggested in his email,
I haven't seen him since,
but it was,
it seemed like he was going to stop doing that.
Whereas,
um,
again,
this what I would absolutely expect,
I mean like bet your life on expect to get from any of these other antagonists
is,
sorry,
you said Lie,
right?
Like this is,
I have the text right here,
I'm going to hold you to that.
Right.
And this is,
this is happening across the board on,
on far more substantial things like,
you know,
whether someone's a racist,
whether it's,
it's like you,
if it's possible to Parse your tweet or your statement or your bad joke as
you're now a Nazi.
Yeah.
Right.
That's what people are going to do to you until the end of time.
And it's just there's,
there's no,
I mean,
I,
I had been living under the illusion that it's possible to play your game so
impeccably so as to close the door,
the door that ever happening.
Like,
like that's like if I'm just going to,
if I just spoke clearly enough,
if I just responded to enough of this crap,
right,
this would stop happening.
I mean,
I never thought that I'm consciously,
because it sounds ridiculous to say,
but,
but like that was a,
that was tacitly presumed in how I was spending my time and energy trying to
close the door to this stuff.
And now I now I basically feel like almost nothing worth
responding to in that.
Yeah.
So when you look back to the time that you either thought that consciously or
not,
does that just seem like naiveté or it just seems like just that the world
seriously shifted partly because of social media where maybe maybe 15 years ago
as someone that,
you know,
staked out some unpopular positions or politically incorrect positions that you
could do it,
you could clean it up in a way that you'd be basically insulated.
But now just because of the craziness of social media,
it just doesn't exist.
Yeah,
I think it's really social media.
I think it's just
you.
I mean there's,
there's never a comment thread that will be clean for you no matter what you do
or say.
It's like,
so if,
if your measure of a controversy worth responding to or stuff that wasn't clear
enough because someone's still confused is what you see in a comment thread or
what you've seen in your at mentions on Twitter,
you'll never be out of hell.
So yeah.
So it was,
uh,
I could have just realized this years before I did,
but it was,
it was a kind of,
you know,
the frog in the boiling water or whether it didn't,
didn't notice it was getting hot,
you know,
as you gradually heated it up.
So,
uh,
I was that frog and I've since jumped out.
So what do you make then of that basic premise that you've laid out there that
for some reason,
whatever is happening on the left,
broadly speaking,
is incapable of having honest conversations.
I mean,
do you at this point,
one of the things when I do the Peterson event,
and I do a little thing about the IDW and just this crew of people,
and I say something about how we ever truly diverse group because we've got Sam
Harris on the left and,
and Ben Shapiro on the right.
And then I throw in a couple of Kanye jokes and some other stuff,
but in,
so in my mind,
I guess you're still part of that.
And I know the labels are all changing and that whole thing,
but what do you make of what's happening on the left?
And do you still consider yourself part of that thing that you're obviously
really struggling with at some level?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I'd be,
I'm,
I'm basically a,
despite that I've said many things about politics over the years.
I'm basically a political politics is the most boring thing in the universe.
Right?
And,
and I've said this before,
one of the things that,
I mean,
strange people actually say this is a good thing.
I think you've said this is a good thing.
I think this is a terrible thing.
The fact that we're talking about politics so much is a sign of something bad.
No,
no,
I think it's terrible.
I just tweeted that the other day.
Okay.
So that's why I want small government so that it can't affect us them.
But I thought you,
I thought you thought that the rise of Trump led to this level of new level of
engagement with all these issues and that would be a good thing.
I think it's,
I mean,
it's,
it's bad that we have an uninformed electorate and that people are disengaged.
I mean,
that's,
but,
uh,
the,
so you,
obviously you want 100% of the people in the country to know,
you know,
how government works.
I mean,
that would be great.
But yeah.
Um,
the fact that politics is so important to people,
the fact that their identity is wrapped up in it,
the fact that,
that you just can't get away from it.
That's a sign of real dysfunction.
That's a sign.
Things not working.
And so,
uh,
you know,
W in my war,
I mean it's,
yeah,
I got sucked into that and I've said as much as you know,
more or less everything I have to say on those issues.
I mean,
they issues aren't changing fast enough for me to have to keep touching it.
Right.
I mean,
Trump isn't that different than he was six months ago,
so I don't have to keep talking about him,
but,
um,
I,
it's just uh,
yeah,
I mean I find it incredibly boring and repetitive and not,
it doesn't really pay attention.
And I like,
like the,
the noises you make seem ineffectual and there's not new in new knowledge coming
your way based on those uses of attention.
So it's,
yeah,
now I'm spending less time on it both just consuming it and putting stuff out
there about it.
Yeah.
Where do you think that leads us?
Just as a society?
Like it does strike me as a sickness.
This,
you know,
as a sort of societal sickness that everything has become political all the
time.
So I do the first part of what you said there I do think is good.
The Trump thing that came in and broke everything up.
The idea that so many people are reevaluating what they think.
That's what I would say is good.
The fact that everything now has become political in sports is absurdly
political now and every TV show and movie and everything,
just nonstop,
endless.
That I think is dangerous because it's just putting up barriers everywhere.
How do we,
how do we sort of bring some of that back?
Well,
I just think [inaudible] again,
we have to resist the slide into politicizing everything.
I think it's the people who are not taken in by the,
I mean it's,
it's disconcerting how many of the examples that come readily to mind are on one
side of the political spectrum.
I,
it's like as someone who's on the left with respect to almost every variable
that can define left and that's what I'm trying to,
it's so much of it is,
is the left,
but the truth is the left is so dominant in journalism and entertainment that
it's kind of high culture academia as well.
It's like,
it's like if you're going to be,
if you can talk about the sources of knowledge and the sources of information
that if you know here to forbidden,
considered valid,
uh,
and then the sources of entertainment.
Um,
your,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know how sports breaks,
but you know,
sports,
uh,
maybe,
um,
maybe sport by sport it might change,
but,
um,
you're talking about a disparate disproportionate influence from the left.
And that's how that's undoubtedly a source of the cluelessness that the left had
about,
you know,
what was going on in the country and the,
and the prospects of Trump winning the election.
You know,
I think that was,
um,
just the naturally and echo chamber effect.
But,
so I think for most people that are watching this,
they're probably agree with you,
right?
Most of my audience is going to agree with that diagnosis.
Do you think the powers that be,
whether it's in the media world or the political establishment or the,
whatever's happening at the universities,
are they getting the message yet?
Do you have any hope that they're actually realizing how toxic this thing has
become?
Well,
they're,
they're getting the message that there's a problem,
but my concern is that the left seems totally capable of just taking a pendulum
swing in the other direction into leftist identity politics.
I think,
you know,
it's hard to know how fully the left has been captured by that,
but uh,
it's mean the reaction to Trump,
you know,
Trump and the left are now mirror images of one of those right now.
And it's,
I mean,
the answer to Trump can't be,
and just take it out of tr off Trump for a second.
Just the answer to the excesses of your identity politics and populism and
unreasoned on the right,
you know,
can't be amplifying all of that on the left.
I just think that's it.
I think it's,
I think it will be just in fact a losing strategy going forward.
And it's just,
it's just,
it is more of a,
I mean,
it's a more,
it's more of a renunciation of everything that makes the left good than it is on
the right.
So like if you go far enough,
right,
you're not expecting to meet kind of rational,
open ended conversation about the nature of reality,
right?
You're expecting to meet,
you know,
neo Nazis and the KKK and that's what you in fact meet.
Right?
Uh,
but my problem is I'm,
I'm meeting the s the same level of demagoguery and dishonesty and cynicism and
just mere gamesmanship on the left in a much,
much closer to to where,
you know,
we all are living like,
so it's like just in interacting with a reporter from,
you know,
Salon or,
or vox,
right?
Like,
like,
like who's,
who's there,
I'm meeting someone who essentially has the intellectual and moral integrity,
but the guy in the white hood,
you know,
over on the right and that asymmetry is,
uh,
is just totally alarming to me.
Yeah.
So I know,
so we'll just do it,
do a couple more minutes
on politics,
shift to some stuff.
So one of the places where obviously we're not completely lined up is sort of
the Trump stuff and the reaction to all of this.
I think as human beings,
I don't think it particularly matters to either one of us what those differences
might be,
but I know our audiences have a little bit of a different feeling on that
perhaps.
Um,
so my general feeling,
again,
I did not vote for Trump.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I would have preferred having a president who I think really understands three
branches of government and the history of America and all of those simple
things.
And that would've been nice in the debates if anyone would've said to him,
do you know what the difference between the legislative and executive and
judicial branches are?
And I think that may be,
could have caused an implosion of the whole thing and all that.
But that being said,
I think the wrecking ball that he put through the machine that was dming us all
down,
that was creating this identity politics situation and everything else that had
been so corroded into the system.
I think where we're at now,
I'm quite hopeful.
I actually sense a lot of fertility for ideas.
I think the fact that this whole crew of people has come together or whether
we're independent or together,
whatever you want to call it,
the fact that there's such interest in all of this,
uh,
I think is all good.
And I see that as sort of a direct result of Trump just shaking up the system.
That being said,
does he lie all the time?
Absolutely.
Do I think they all lie all the time.
Yeah.
That Obama lie about if you like your doctor you can keep it.
The Syrian red line,
blah blah blah.
It's just Trump does a different series of lies and does the much more blatantly
[inaudible] necessary either.
I guess
I can't give you that last thing on,
on the scale of the line.
Cause I think it's,
it's orders of magnitude worse.
I mean like not even just one order of magnitude worse.
It's like a hundred fold worse with Trump.
So all right.
So if you take those two though,
so if you like your doctor,
you can keep your doctor.
Obamacare,
obviously it was his biggest public policy,
domestic public policy thing.
So that's a pretty big lie.
And they pretty much admitted that he knew he was saying it because,
yeah,
I mean,
whether,
whether that was a lie or not or whether he just reneged on a promise or I'd be
like the red line.
I don't really do as a lie.
I just view that as a failure of nerve.
It's like he drew a red line that he probably shouldn't have drawn because he,
he,
if he thought about it,
he knew he wasn't going to go to war over it.
Um,
and then he made us look weak because he didn't,
you know,
he hit the line was crossed and we didn't respond.
Um,
I think that was,
but it's just where we were living in a world where you would have a whole new
cycle over Obama wearing a tan suit.
Right.
And now we're living in a world where a porn star can say,
listen,
you know,
he's lying about this and I have evidence and it's like,
it's so it is eclipsed by the next lie he tells by the end of the bad news
cycle.
Right.
So it's just,
um,
I mean you,
I mean,
it's literally true to say that Obama's presidency would have been completely
derailed by anyone of maybe a hundred things you could say Donald Trump has said
or done in the last year.
I mean,
not,
way beyond 10 things.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I can't list them now,
but I mean almost anything he does on a weekly basis,
if not a daily basis.
Had you seen Obama do it in that period of the earth that we can call the deadly
recollect?
Would it really derailed in Obama presidency?
Because to me it was like the media was so far up his,
but they could have pretty much gotten away with anything.
Well,
I get what you're saying.
Yeah.
They focused on Tan suits and s and silly nonsense.
But to me,
I see that as almost like it's because you guys weren't doing your job,
you should have been digging a little bit more or whatever.
Well,
no,
but I,
I think it's actually true to say that Obama was basically a,
you know,
as honest as a politician can be and still be a politician.
I mean,
I think,
I'm sure he lied about things,
right?
Yeah.
But there's,
there's no story on Obama being just this depraved person behind closed doors
who get,
who's a,
who's a con artist,
who gets away with everything that he can get away with.
Uh,
who's trailing a long list of,
you know,
business and interpersonal casualties.
Who will tell you if you put them on camera or you can't get them privately.
They,
he's the worst person they've ever met.
Right.
That's his president now.
It's just that it's a completely different personality.
Um,
and,
uh,
I think that,
I think so whatever happens,
let's say good.
Let's say we're living in a universe where having a,
a uniquely narcissistic,
selfish,
shallow personality in this position of power works out.
Well,
let's just say that I mean a lot.
So let's just take your wrecking ball theory.
He's kind of swung through here.
He's disrupted everything.
You know,
I do view him,
as I said,
I've said before as a kind of evil Chauncey Gardner character.
I don't view him as this sort of mass.
I think Scott Adams is completely out to lunch on this.
I don't think he's this genius manipulator.
I mean,
he's got,
he's got some talents obviously,
but I think you think it's much less calculating,
much less calculus.
Yeah.
I don't think him contradicting himself.
Two sentences later,
right when he says,
you know this amazing letter,
you'd all like to read this letter and then he says two sentences later.
I haven't read the letter.
That's not calculated.
He's just not,
doesn't have the cog.
He can't take the cognitive overhead.
Even figure out what you know,
what was logically implied by the last thing you said.
Right.
So He's,
the truth is he's not,
he lies all the time,
but worse than line.
And this is the great distinction that the philosopher Harry Frankfurt made in
his book on Bullshit.
Worse than line is that he's bullshitting all the time.
And the difference between line and bullshitting is it,
if I'm going to lie to you,
I'm paying attention to what I know.
React.
I know what is true.
I know you know what is true and I'm trying to insert a lye into the space
provided in a way that you won't notice.
Right?
Like I'm having to keep track of reality in order to lie to you successfully.
I understand your logical expectations.
I understand that.
If I tell you that,
you know,
I was an hour late here because the traffic was so bad.
I can't say in the next sentence,
oh,
I left an hour late from my house.
Right?
So like so,
um,
uh,
so the bullshit or isn't doing any of that,
that bullshit or is just talking right and therefore has renounced the reality
testing he has to do to live successfully and he's just,
he,
he has the burden is not on him to make any sense at all in the end.
And um,
that to an amazing degree,
not entirely,
I think he does actually lie strategically sometimes.
But to an amazing degree and this is what I think is so harmful about his,
whatever happens with North Korea or anything else that we might care about to
an amazing degree.
He has revealed that half of our society will accept somebody who is just
bullshitting all the time about things.
Great and small.
I mean,
it doesn't matter how important or how inconsequential porn stars,
you know,
what,
what just happened with the g seven,
you know what was said behind closed doors,
what he's going to say to,
to uh,
some maniac with,
with nukes.
Um,
there's just a,
we've completely forsaken any expectation of a reality based conversation and
many people seem to revel in it.
Many people seem to think this is just,
this is just good fun.
This is like,
this is,
you know,
it's a bit of the wrecking ball theory gone to some nihilistic extreme where
it's just,
let's just,
you know,
let's just burn it all out.
You know,
like,
like there's just nothing,
you know,
that there's nothing,
there was nothing we're worth maintaining about our institutions,
about our norms,
about our traditions,
about,
you know,
the expectations of our,
of our,
of other countries that are allies,
you know,
or like,
who cares if,
if all of our traditional allies don't know what to think about the president
because he said one thing five minutes ago and he says the opposite thing now.
And they're all left with our jaws on the floor.
Right?
That's just comedy for what,
40% of America?
Um,
I think there's a real consequence to that.
Cause I,
the,
because what,
what,
what Trump has revealed is that there's a space for a truly terrible calculating
person,
you know,
like the sinister person with a real ideology,
not just someone potentially worse than him.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
we've just,
we've proven to ourselves that literally anyone who,
who can connect certain dots,
I mean,
anyone who can connect the dots of,
you know,
I'm not even sure what these dots are,
but I mean,
obviously Trump connected,
some of them,
you know,
fame.
And,
and a certain kind of charisma,
um,
you know,
the,
a kind of populist,
an ability to,
to,
to strike the populous note in a way that's compelling.
Someone who's could be way worse and way smarter and have a very different
agenda,
um,
uh,
can become president.
And I think that's,
you know,
I mean it's good perhaps it's good to know that,
but it's just,
I think
we now know that about ourselves.
Yeah.
Is this then weird?
So I think,
you know,
that I'm certainly not a nihilist and I'm definitely not somebody that wanted to
burn the whole thing down,
but I,
but I do view this reckoning as basically good as long as this,
this other person doesn't magically appear out of it.
And I also sense that,
that the time of craziness that we're in right now and this endless inability to
have these honest conversations and I,
and I agree with you on his basic
management of truth or whatever you want,
whatever you want.
Management of treatment is an interesting phrase,
but whatever that is that I sense there is going to be a rebound towards sanity
that at some point you can't always have the wrecking ball always have the guy
that's flipping everything over and destroying it and that if our institutions
are strong enough and if there's enough sane people out there and enough people
that are listening to thoughtful conversations and I think we both agree there's
a lot of people are growing in that regard that the next version of whatever
happens at an election is going to come from something much saner.
Yeah.
I think the scenery from before where we were before because that's where we
were just getting a lot of bullshit from the media and from everything else that
we might actually get a rebounded to sanity.
No,
cause I,
what I see is the,
the Republican party has been destroyed by the Republican Party,
has become Trump's party answers this populous pandering.
Uh,
I mean they're just all trying to figure out what to do in his wake.
But nobody,
I mean this,
there's no coherent platform anymore there.
And as we've said,
the left has swung into this,
uh,
insane,
just,
just victimology,
echo chamber of identity politics where everyone's a racist,
right?
So,
um,
I guess maybe that's sort of the root of where our little disconnect is on this
cause I fear that much more.
I think that that thing that's happening on the left,
this identity politics thing,
I think that's the thing that could actually truly upend the entire American
experiment.
The idea that we would end up looking at each other only on these immutable
characteristics and hiring each other only on these things and having quotas and
ripping apart the,
the good pieces of multiculturalism that we've done here better than anybody and
the melting pot that we've done better,
that I will cause us to all be horrifically suspicious of each other and angry
at each other.
Really for no reason other than the way we look and I'm not discounting anything
you're saying about what's happening on the right.
Although I do see a streak of libertarianism on the right that I really like.
I think there actually has been a rebirth.
You know,
a guy like Shapiro is obviously not a real Trump guy at heart and he's arguing a
lot of libertarians stuff that I like.
I mean maybe you don't like it as much.
I think it's a decent place to be arguing from,
but I guess maybe that is where our,
our little disconnected is on that,
that the thing on the left eye view as much scarier.
I think it's a much more of an immediate threat.
And I say that knowing full well that Trump has the nuclear codes.
So maybe that's,
maybe that's a little,
yeah,
I mean I think they're both enormous problems.
I don't know which,
I mean,
you know,
the Trump thing could seem fine until something horrific happens,
right?
So it's like,
and you know,
it's just how it is in fact hard to know what's happening and what risks we're
running.
So it was like,
you know,
the economy seems to be doing good.
What metric
by that the stock market has imploded,
right?
So,
but only
consumer confidence is high.
Black and Latino women
climate is really low.
I mean they,
there are ways to parse all of those numbers that,
that are less optimistic.
So you know,
like the employment numbers are low because lots of people just falling out of
the job search,
but,
and the,
you know,
the stock market,
I think there's something like 8% of Americans are in the stock market.
You know,
there's like 92% of Americans are not even exposed to the stock market.
Right.
Or at least directly.
So,
um,
those numbers could be a little off,
but it's something like that.
The,
um,
but all of that would change radically the moment.
Something,
you know,
the,
the left's worse fears about Trump or realize them,
but the moment he does something that just gets,
you know,
gets us far closer to obvious,
war or actually into one.
Um,
and it's clearly the wrong war.
Uh,
you know,
the fact that,
I mean,
I think,
I think that the,
the u s no longer stand,
at least in the eyes of the world,
the US no longer stands for sanity on some fundamental questions of human values
and be like,
you know,
whether it's,
climate change and environmentalism and doing something sane with respect to
that or,
um,
you know,
human rights.
I mean,
he just,
he just took a meeting with,
with,
uh,
the perhaps the greatest human rights violator.
Uh,
certainly the current generation.
Um,
and humor,
it's just clear now that the US will,
will glad hand a dictator and say nothing about the fact that he's running a
gulag system and they have been for,
for decades,
uh,
that used to,
they used to be on thinkable and that's,
and that,
that,
that extinguishes a certain hope of kind of moral high ground that the rest of
the world,
I think rightly t depended on us for.
And given the current occupant of the Oval Office,
you know,
we've completely abandoned that.
So I think,
but it's hard to,
it's hard to price in those changes.
I don't know what the consequences of,
of all of that is.
Right.
So I guess the part that still seems odd to me is like,
you know,
when Obama ran,
he said,
you know,
we have to sit down with these people.
He said he wanted to sit down with doc Medinah job,
no,
with no,
uh,
you know,
no prior discussions or whatever.
That's basically what Trump did here.
Now I'm not saying Trump's the right guy to do it,
maybe is in some insane way,
and maybe it isn't.
But Obama,
most of those cases,
there would've been some,
uh,
lambasting of the person about human rights.
You know,
it's like the standard,
if it was Hillary Clinton doing any of these things,
yeah.
At least you know,
there would be
the norm of,
of acknowledging that,
that,
I mean,
so somebody will just compare what Trump said about Kim Jong on the statements
were eating cake to what's actually going on.
I mean,
so,
so we have someone who is presiding over these,
the starvation and just,
yeah,
I mean beyond or well,
and immiseration of his people.
And it's like if you are caught saying the wrong thing or passing the wrong book
to your neighbor,
or if you tune your radio to receive a broadcast from South Korea,
you're sent to the Gulag and your progeny are sent to the Gulag and they're down
to the third generation.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
that's the punishment for this.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we have the president United States saying that he's a great guy.
He's a,
he's an intelligent guy.
He loves his people.
And that's a verbatim quote.
I'm not surprised by that.
I mean it's just,
it's like I don't even know what I mean.
Is there,
is there anyone in this country
who,
I mean it's just like there's so many layers at which we have lost sight of
reality here.
That's like,
it's a,
I don't know where the free fall stops.
Like on one level there's a sense that
he's,
he's lying,
right?
Like he's saying something he knew us know is untrue.
Right?
So like he,
he knows what's going on.
He knows what life is like in North Korea,
Korea.
So he knows that to say that this man loves his people is a misrepresentation.
But what do people actually think it I think,
I think it's,
there's another layer beyond that.
No,
he actually doesn't know that.
Like he's so ignorant of what's happening in the world that he's just talking
and there's,
there's no burden on him to represent reality at all.
Or
there's a layer beyond that.
It's simply doesn't matter.
Like,
like the difference between those two things,
lying and bullshitting doesn't matter.
And we're not even going to spend the,
the,
the nanosecond it takes to judge between them.
Uh,
and beyond that,
we're,
uh,
we're not even going to notice that he said anything strange there.
And that's,
that's kind of where most of the country is.
It's like we now have someone in office who will say things that make absolutely
no sense and they,
they are meant to map on the most consequential examples of human suffering in
our time,
right?
And the most consequential risks we run as a civilization.
We're talking about nuclear war here and the conversations that can be had to,
to prevent it.
And he's saying things that are not only just untrue and obscene,
really untrue.
No one's even noticing.
And no one's even noticing that no one's noticing and be like,
so this is like,
I don't even know where we are now,
but it's just like,
I don't think there's a name for this.
Right.
And,
um,
how would I think that matters?
Do you think we have until if what you're saying is right,
how many firewalls left are there before we're really in,
like,
like some true Dystopian,
complete inability to communicate that.
But let me just clarify here is,
I'm not even judging whether anything bad happened in Singapore,
like I,
so it's totally possible that the,
that the evil Chauncey Gardner,
uh,
character could be the thing that successfully gets us to have a better
relationship with,
with North Korea.
So I think that's what's that?
That's possible.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying I know that's impossible.
It doesn't sound like a great bet to me.
And it doesn't,
it's not the way I would.
It's not,
and even if it's possible,
I don't think it's the best possible strategy.
It'd be better to have someone who actually read the briefing books,
knows the history of negotiations,
knows the possibility that he's being duped.
Um,
it's paying attention to all of that,
even while,
let's say,
playing like the mad man,
if in fact that's the right strategy in this game of chicken.
Uh,
but so there's nothing to optimal about this,
but,
but I'm just saying I'm not clear.
I'm not saying that,
that my worrying about the,
that what's happening,
um,
is not predicated on the claim that Oh,
this whole thing with North Korea is going to be a disaster if it's successful.
That still doesn't answer my primary concern about what we've done to ourselves
in terms of our politics.
Yeah.
So how do we negotiate those two things?
Let's just say for a second that despite all the lies and I'm with Ya,
he lies about absolutely everything.
Okay.
Despite all of this craziness and nonsense and all of that,
that basically four years past,
let's say the economy's basically fine,
we don't get into some extra intractable war.
Let's say something good comes out of the North Korea situation.
Basically things have been okay.
You know,
there isn't some massive terror attack or something.
I would say we,
we've dodged many,
many bullets and that we got very lucky.
Yeah.
What's impossible to argue is that this is all a brilliant plan that has been
thought through from the beginning on the part of Trump.
I think that's,
I mean,
there's just no evidence for that at all.
Right?
It's not that he is,
he is deeply informed about world history and current events and all of the,
all of the information one would think you would need to know to,
to game this out.
I had some genius level four dimensional chess,
right?
Right.
Uh,
to follow the Scott Adams program.
And uh,
so that's not happening.
So what we could live in a world where having someone who have kind of
fundamentally is just a reality TV show,
star thrust into this position of immense responsibility.
We could live in a world where that can work out in surprising ways,
or at least not cause some kind of disaster.
I hope we live in that world.
I mean,
I'm,
you know,
I hope that he succeeds in every way we would want a president to succeed.
Uh,
and then I also hope he doesn't get reelected.
And I was like,
I,
I think it's still,
it's,
it's obvious to me that we're paying an immense price,
even if terrible things don't happen.
So that happen were
terrible.
Things don't happen.
And the left sort of continues with the track that I think we both see it done.
Right.
Could you possibly vote for one of those people?
Like would you feel that this is,
this could override every wall?
It depends who the is and what the,
what the tradeoffs are.
Ma,
I think,
you know,
I,
in my world almost anyone would be better than Trump,
but you know,
give me the,
the sufficiently obnoxious choice on the left.
And you know,
I would,
I could rethink that is,
I think it's,
uh,
well I think,
I think you mean rethink that not to vote for Trump,
but you'd end up voting for third party here.
Yeah,
I may,
uh,
or that it wouldn't matter.
You know,
we could be in a situation where it's just both sides are so terrible that,
you know,
let's just toss a coin.
Yeah.
But it's just,
it should be,
I mean,
it's,
I don't know how we got here.
We've got more than 300 million people in this country.
There are many really impressive people in this country.
How is it that we can't feel the candidate who has obvious depth of knowledge
are obvious moral compass and you know,
sound goal.
Do you think it's just that nobody that was truly good,
that was truly knowledgeable,
that was truly decent and all the things that we'd really want from a president
will never do it now in a time when every one of your texts will be gone through
every year.
Internet search history,
your every little relationship you've ever had that the ability to dig deeper
and dive into more of just the nonsense that no good person who's ever lived a
full life and made mistakes and done drugs or whatever else it is,
would it ever want to do it?
So instead you get sort of this shameless person who has done probably
everything and all sorts of crazy things,
but just doesn't care what you know,
where as a a good decent person who wants to live a decent life and have a
family and all that.
And I'm not even commenting on it.
Seemed like he,
his family really loves him.
So I don't mean that,
but that just someone,
the person that you're looking for in that imaginary equation would never want
to do it.
That's not someone who would opt in.
Well,
I think there are people who are,
who will opt in,
who are normal.
I just,
whether or not they will get noticed and get promoted too.
So like for instance,
I just interviewed a guy who you may not have heard of,
Andrew Yang who is already declared his candidacy for 2020 as a democrat.
He's a silicon valley guy.
Uh,
I just recorded a podcast with him.
I think he'll be the next one.
I released a very interesting guy whose whole platform it seems is universal
basic income.
I mean,
he's just,
he's looking at what's happening in tech and automation and AI and he says,
you know this in,
as many of us have said,
or at least worried that that there will be jobs lost in,
in the near term that aren't coming back and aren't converting to new.
Gee,
it's not,
it's not like,
you know,
any analogy you want to draw to previous moments and in economic history,
there will be truck drivers losing jobs and we're not going to retrain those
truck drivers as software engineers and,
uh,
this is going to be,
forget about all the other high falutin concerns about Ai.
This is to be catastrophic if we don't figure out how to deal with it.
And he thinks ubi as a solution than he,
he,
um,
his book,
he wrote a book that,
that in very stark terms puts it all in perspective,
his book as the war on normal people.
Uh,
but I,
I've just,
I'll have a podcast where that's probably out guys where your next book.
Yeah.
Normal people,
but he's a,
you know,
he's,
he's very articulate guy.
He's,
he's,
you know,
thought about these issues deeply,
whether he's right about ubi being the panacea.
I think it's certainly open for debate,
but,
um,
he strikes me as,
I mean,
I don't know him,
I just did one podcast with him,
but he strikes me as like,
you know,
completely sane,
normal,
non fame seeking person who just wants to screw up his life by becoming present.
And because he's worried he's just simply worried about the future his kids are
going to inherit.
Yeah.
All right,
so one more on the political stuff that will shift to some other stuff.
So did you catch,
um,
I know you've been on the show a couple of times.
Uh,
did you happen to catch a real time on Friday?
Received the clip of bill basically saying that he's sort of hoping for
recession because that'll wake people up.
Did,
did you have no,
no.
I asked her if I miss,
I'm a,
I'm at least a week behind,
but no,
I didn't.
Yeah.
So bill in effect said that if it takes a recession to derail this thing,
that,
that he'd be for that.
Right.
And you know,
I like bill a lot.
You know,
I,
I'd love to have them on the show to discuss some of this stuff.
But I thought that moment of him saying that a guy who's proud of no idea what
he's worth,
he's probably worth at least 50 million bucks or something crazy,
which I don't begrudge him any of that.
Of course,
that's what he said.
They're so caught me as just this is what people hate about liberals,
liberals,
whatever the,
you know,
or lefties or whatever it is.
Like this idea that yeah,
you may not like Trump debate,
joke about them all the time and all this stuff and you may think he's lying all
the time,
but that what you would want is a recession,
which you'll survive cause you've got millions and millions of dollars.
But it did make the,
my first thought when I saw it was that right after the election,
for as much as you despise this man and are so fearful of all of the things that
he will wrought upon us,
you,
you made the analogy about the pilot in the plane and I feel like that's the
right analogy.
And I thought that's what we need right now.
And I discussed this a little bit with Rogan today and that's where his take was
also.
Oh,
sorry.
So I haven't seen the clip from bill.
And so I can imagine at least two charitable interpretations of it that take
that,
that a callousness off at one would just be the idea that we're running such an
intolerable risk with this guy at the helm.
And the only way he's going to be voted out is to have something like a
recession.
So there definitely was an element of that,
right?
So like,
and it's like,
so this is,
we're running every day you wake up and don't think about it.
You're running the risk of nuclear catastrophe with this guy that's,
you know,
50% more than it should be or that would otherwise be.
Uh,
and that the,
the price of that,
again,
a price,
you're not aware of pain because we're just talking about hypotheticals,
right?
It's just risk,
increased risk.
Uh,
it's worth doing this.
Some other,
you know,
catastrophic,
uh,
change.
If it's the thing that's gonna get us a new president.
And,
and so I mean that,
yeah,
that would be defensible if you actually thought that that was in fact the
situation we're in.
Um,
but you know,
I don't know what he was actually thinking.
Yeah.
Um,
isn't it nice that you give the charitable interpretation?
You don't want to just do what you were
certainly,
certainly not surprising in this case because he's a friend,
but it's a,
I would,
you know,
I try to do that even when I'm thinking about it.
I mean,
truth is,
I do that with Trump.
Like I've been a thing that I find someone tolerable.
Yeah.
About the left is also exemplified in how they attack Trump for things that he's
not guilty of.
Clearly.
I mean,
there's no one who despises this man more than me.
I'm out.
I mean it's,
yeah.
I don't know how you compare these things,
but like,
yeah,
I will,
I'll go to the mat with anyone [inaudible] to destroy later.
I mean,
I can,
I can talk endlessly about what's wrong with this guy.
Yeah.
But when people,
when people on the left or did not,
I mean,
I'm not,
I don't mean just fringe left.
I mean the New York Times,
yeah.
Go after him for things that seem clearly just calculated to mislead.
I mean,
they're just disingenuous.
Um,
it's,
it's just a bit,
I get as annoyed by that as by anything.
So I mean,
I'm,
I'm PR within my own mind.
I feel pretty balanced in how careful I am,
you know?
So like for,
I mean to take the,
um,
like the ms 13 thing.
I mean,
have you seen what's going on with ms 13 on Long Island?
Did you,
did you watch that front line?
Uh,
I didn't see the front line.
Okay.
But,
you know,
it's like going on.
I mean,
so it's the fact that anyone is minimizing the significance of how horrible this
is.
Yeah.
Right.
It's just,
and playing politics with that and catching him saying like,
you know,
these people are animals.
Right.
And then do you using that to mean that he thinks everyone coming from Latin
America as an animal?
Um,
it's,
uh,
I mean that's,
it's just so toxic.
Here's w I view that as different somehow than,
all right,
forget the buzz feeds in salons and that whole set that we already talked about,
but this thing now with the New York Times and CNN where they're doing this now.
Yeah.
That to me is something that is truly,
systemically that's different and that's extremely dangerous.
Like what could possibly be happening there at,
uh,
at a sort of systemic level that makes sense that they can get away with this
stuff?
Well,
no,
they know five minutes later it's going to be exposed.
Well,
I don't know if I know that,
but yeah,
but I think the fact that you see it that way is a measure of
how important a reality based conversation is and how different the expectation
is of something like the New York Times versus something like Breitbart.
Right,
right.
So like,
it matters that the New York Times gets it wrong.
It matters that the New York Times is it all click baity.
Right.
And so,
and then when you compare that to something like Breitbart,
you know,
it's just,
there's a fundamentally different expectation.
And so,
um,
we'll that's people,
people give me shit all the time.
Little,
I'm always attacking New York Times and CNN.
It's like those are the ones I think mattered.
Yeah,
no,
it does.
You want me to tackle the ones everyone else's attacking or that I don't expect
to do real journalism.
They're just.com.
That's all they are.
Yeah.
But I mean it matters.
It matters across the board because people are confused by those people think
that vox is like the New York time.
Right.
And,
and it's confusing because you can find articles on box that are fantastic.
I mean,
it's just,
there's a,
there's a real,
um,
range of quality you get everywhere now and,
and you,
there shouldn't be a wide range in something like the New York Times.
Right.
And,
and,
and it's,
and we're seeing this,
you know,
like as any of us get close to being part of the news story,
right?
Whether it's a directly on you or it's told about one of your friends.
It's like New York Times.
I mean,
someone I know at the New York Times,
Bret Stephens who,
who moved from the Wall Street Journal and now he's an opinion writer in New
York Times.
I know the piece he just went after Ilan for,
I mean,
it was just a pure clickbait hit piece that was just,
it was just,
you know,
Breitbart level trash.
Right.
I mean,
it was,
it was wrong in every respect.
Um,
apart from the fact that it,
that it summarized some of the economic skepticism about Tesla,
but I mean he's,
you know,
wasn't really the issue.
No,
it may because he basically said that Ilan is silicon valley's Trump.
Right.
And a con man.
And it's just,
just know he's got this.
No,
they're there.
He's lying about everything.
Um,
I mean,
if,
if ever there were a person you can't say is,
is without substance and is just a pure con man,
it's Ilan.
I mean like,
it's like he,
he could fail to do half the things he's promising to do and he does more than
the next product,
most productive hundred people.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
it's insane.
So,
and I,
you know,
uh,
it was,
it was hilarious because I,
this all was time with my getting off Twitter,
as I said,
by like 95%,
but I was on long enough to notice this and,
and,
and just take a shot at,
at,
uh,
Brett in,
you know,
in response,
um,
because it was intolerable to me,
but the New York Times somewhat respectful way,
right?
Yeah.
And then you didn't do it the way that most people do,
which was just like blurted out a snow.
No.
Would I let him know?
But cause I was,
I'm a fan of breads.
I publicly celebrated also on Twitter,
his move to the New York Times.
It's like I congratulated him and you know,
I think he's a,
he's a very smart guy,
you know,
for whatever re,
dogmatic reason.
He was sort of destined to get this,
this wrong,
but he's so totally wrong that it is just,
is a real consequence.
The New York Times can't afford to be this wrong about,
in this case,
you know,
the prospects of a company like Tesla and a cleantech and you know,
I mean it's just,
it was a,
mmm.
All of this connects obviously with climate change and,
you know,
huge important issues.
And I think that one for,
I don't know Brett personally,
but it seems like what,
what this was all about was because Alanna was attacking the media because he
was unhappy about the way some stuff was reported and then Brett was obviously
being defensive over the media.
Yeah.
Um,
but I was very pleased watching the lines thread on this because I was like,
yeah,
we need more people to be attacking this,
you know,
otherwise the times won't turn around.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know whether he's doing himself,
uh,
harm by engaging in that way.
I mean,
he could be just something that happens to somebody once they crossed,
you know,
the,
the 20 million mark on Twitter a cycle like,
or you just get those,
you become like Trump in that respect and you just decide to,
you know,
use Twitter that way.
But,
uh,
it's,
I mean,
on one level it's refreshing that you have someone that you have a CEO who's
kind of this transparent with what he's thinking and this,
and just engaging on all of these issues with,
with,
you know,
people in his ad mentions.
But,
um,
it's,
I dunno,
I thought,
you know,
I think it's,
again,
I think,
I think social media,
the net result for virtually everyone is you're lucky to get back to zero.
You know,
like that if you,
if you're going to take an inventory of what was gained in the end by all of
this,
all of the energy you've,
you've spent fighting with people or correcting the record,
it's,
you're,
you're lucky to have gotten it.
You can check all the time that you've owned someone versus,
you know,
all the times they owned you.
And all right.
So let,
let's put all of that aside for a second.
I do want to do a sort of deep dive on the,
on the Jordan stuff.
Cause I think maybe we can set the table in a nice way for your conversations,
but what's on your mind more than anything else right now that's not political
or not unrelated to the conversation with Jordan?
Or like what,
what are you really thinking about right now?
Well,
I'm thinking more about the kind of core things that interest me.
Like the nature of consciousness,
you know,
and,
and just how to live a good life given the fact that we wake up every day not
knowing how long we've got and we're absolutely sure that we don't get this day
again.
You know,
so it's just like how to,
how to meaningfully engage moment to moment in our lives in a way that's
rewarding and,
and,
uh,
minimizes unnecessary suffering and increases joy and,
and insight and creativity.
And,
and so for me,
as you know,
meditation is part of that certainly.
And,
uh,
I've just,
I've just come out with meditation APP that is now in Beta in on apple and the
Android Beta LP.
It's probably about a month away.
This has been taken completely mystifying to me that it's taken me this long to
build an app and talk about something you doing over there.
You didn't understand.
Um,
but I mean really,
it literally is just a glorified MP three player and he was taken me longer than
two years and just vast expense to build this thing.
Uh,
but in any case,
I'm,
I'm happy with the,
um,
theater ration that's coming out now.
And so that's,
I'm going to,
it's not just a meditation APP,
but it will have my podcast and other content I put on it.
But,
uh,
I'm thinking my,
my withdrawal from the toxicity of social media and,
and the political conversations has led me to just clear,
uh,
a lot more space frankly for four things that I think are,
are,
uh,
interesting and,
and profound in a durable way that where you're not going to look back five
years from now or 20 years from now and wonder why you spent your time on those
things.
And so much of,
of all of our lives,
but you know,
like my,
my life and my public life in particular has been spent on things where when I
look back at it,
it just looks like one opportunity cause after another and be like virtually
everything that I,
I'm well known for talking about has been a waste of time.
And that's,
it's,
it's in some sense of necessary.
It's not that I've squandered my time in a way that I didn't think was
necessary,
but
it woke up a lot of people along the way.
Hence,
hence I felt it was necessary,
but it was an opportunity cost.
It's like,
it's like it's,
it's,
it's in some level a on some of it,
it's trying to get to zero is like can we get to the starting point where we
then can advance the conversation pass what we should had every reason to
already understand to be true.
So I think a lot of people are lining up behind that.
And again,
it still gets to where I think this thing is fertile right now.
I do think there has been some sort of shift.
I can see it when I'm with the Peterson audiences,
I can see it just,
there's a new conversation happening that people are starting to arm themselves
with.
Like how do we move forward through this craziness,
whether we all agree on belief or lack of belief or religion or some of that
other,
some of that other stuff.
Um,
Yup.
You know,
one of the things that you told me the first time we met,
which now it was the first time you did my shows,
September 9th,
2015 it seems like 87 lifetimes ago that that was the first show.
The first show.
Yeah.
That was at our TV way back.
Right in which the whole purpose of having you on the show was to clean up so
much of the mess.
And I think we did a pretty decent job but at the same time because of all this,
you know the people that want to drag you just keep dragging you.
But one of the most interesting things,
and I know you don't believe in Karma in a,
in any kind of traditional,
but that you were on real time to talk about waking up,
talking to him about the book tour that was about a guy does spirituality
without religion.
Thus your book tour got ransacked by that.
So it's like Eh,
in Karma,
but it's kind of an,
it's just like Whoa,
that's something pretty profound.
I've actually never thought about what my life would've been like without social
media at that point.
Like I like the cause cause the consequence in my life of the of that,
you know,
fight with Ben Affleck on real time was basically a year spent digging out from
that charge.
I was like,
okay so your,
your views about Islam are racist.
Like anyone ever called you racist before that or bigoted or anyone of any
consequences?
Like was there anything,
well,
I mean I'm sure,
I'm sure,
but I don't,
I don't remember it being something I,
that I had to respond to.
Yeah,
I think and,
but it was just that was so
captivating to people and there was so much,
so much spun out after that.
But again,
had I not been on social media,
it might have in my world,
it might've blown over and in two weeks.
Right.
I might've not felt there was anything to respond to.
And a,
I could have just moved on directly to talking about meditation and a rational
take on spirituality and um,
I don't know.
But it's certainly possible if that's the case.
So.
All right,
so meditation,
what do you think is the right amount then of spirituality for the amount of
people that are watching this,
that maybe you were on the fence about religion or,
or actually are,
are atheists,
but that are trying to figure out some spiritual sense of going forward and
cleaning out some of the clutter that we're inundated with.
What do you think is sort of the easiest way to enter that,
that world?
Well,
I'm sure this is something Jordan and I are going to get,
uh,
we're going to butt heads over.
But it would be the level at which people have been primed to think about
meaning and profundity and all and the sacred and spirituality by traditional
religions,
especially Abrahamic religion is,
uh,
certainly not necessary.
And I,
you know,
I would argue it's not at all useful when you talk about what the,
the opportunity actually is and what's what's available to you as like,
as a conscious agent in this moment.
Um,
and it's not an accident that people are going to the east and to the east,
the eastern tradition for insight with respect to this particular variable of
just,
just how to pay attention to experience closely enough.
So it was to notice something worth noticing in the West.
People have been praying to Yahweh for 2000 years to do that.
Right?
And it's,
it's,
it's explicitly dualistic.
It's explicitly,
uh,
hostage to this notion of revelation,
the notion of a God with whom you're in relationship,
who can,
who can be propitiated with prayer or not.
It's just,
it's hooked to all of the mythologizing that,
that Jordan is so enamored of.
Uh,
and in my world it's totally unnecessary and totally all of that's confusing.
It's like,
it's needlessly confusing,
right?
Um,
and it would be just as confusing to go to Tibetan Buddhism and acquire all the
religiosity of,
of the Tibetans or to go to,
you know,
the Indian tradition and take on all of the,
the,
the ordinary forms of Hinduism,
you know,
the,
the exoteric,
you know,
non,
uh,
that the dualistic forms of Hinduism.
So you're like,
you know,
just how much time should we spend thinking about the monkey God,
Hanuman,
or,
you know,
Ganache the elephant headed Ganash and it,
did she have a really,
you know,
terrorist head off and put an elephant head on there.
And it's like,
do we,
it's like these books you could run the same game that Jordan is doing with
Judeo the Judeo Christian tradition with Hinduism.
And think that somehow all of that,
all of that mythmaking and story telling is necessary.
I'm not saying there's no,
I'm not saying you can't find people who have some good results in their lives
by thinking of,
you know,
thinking they're in relationship to Honamin every day.
Uh,
but there's,
there's something truly universal and not at all bound by culture and not at all
bound by history about the nature of consciousness.
And that can be realized directly.
And that,
and meditation is simply a tool for doing that.
And it just,
it is just an accident and an explainable accident,
but it's an,
it's an accident of history that there are certain traditions that got the point
very early in an an in a way that's uncontaminated by needless concepts.
Uh,
and certain traditions don't have it at all.
And,
and Buddhism is,
is unique in that you can find a strand in it that really is not,
it's not even a religion.
It is just simply a methodology for paying attention to the nature of
consciousness.
And you can,
and you need not take on any Buddhism,
you know,
even as a philosophy in order to do that.
And so,
you know,
[inaudible] you know,
my book waking up and,
and whenever I talk about this,
uh,
yeah,
I try to boil it down to here somewhere if you want to reference it.
And I still remember what I think on that regard.
But yeah,
you can,
you can get to the heart of the matter without presupposing any religious
nonsense.
And the heart of the matter is that,
you know,
consciousness again,
as I said,
is the one thing in this universe that can't be an illusion.
I mean,
what's,
so whatever we are,
whatever,
however,
consciousness is integrated with physical reality,
that's still a question mark.
Whether we're being run on the,
you know,
the,
uh,
supercomputer in some,
you know,
future state of humanity and we're just a simulation or whether,
whether we're,
you know,
have been invented by aliens,
this,
this universe can be strained in ways that we can't even imagine.
Still.
There's,
there's this,
there's this moment where something seems to be happening.
There's something that is like to be you,
whatever you are,
right?
Whatever the physics of things this second.
Yes.
That is the,
that is the fact of consciousness,
that that is what we mean by consciousness.
I mean this,
it's possible to define consciousness in other ways,
but those,
those,
those definitions are,
are,
are confusing.
Do you think Jordan disagrees with that point because when we haven't talked
about it but no,
I would doubt.
I don't think you can coherently disagree with that and it's like this is,
this is,
this could be a dream,
right?
You could be asleep and dreaming and we're not even doing this podcast,
but still the fact that it seems like something at this moment to be you,
that is what that is what we mean by consciousness and
it is just a fact that you can pay attention to that circumstance carefully
enough to discover certain things that are profound and surprising and do
actually link up with the phenomenology of religion.
Let me do,
I mean,
so hell,
at least some of what Jesus said about what it's like to be Jesus is,
is discoverable as a property of your own consciousness now.
And you don't have to be a Christian to do that.
And so it is with Buddha or any other,
you know,
any uh,
other matriarch or patriarch of,
of the world's religious traditions.
And you don't need these,
these additional cultural artifacts that clearly are the product of the fact
that,
that people were isolated from one another and speaking different languages and
never corresponding about their claims.
Um,
there's just,
there is a deeper universal culture,
free reality which we are subjectively and that that is consciousness and,
and its contents in each moment.
And one thing you can realize about consciousness is that the self you take
yourself to be in each moment,
that the feeling that you're riding around in your head as the unchanging center
of your life,
that's an illusion.
And you can discover that to be an illusion.
You can,
you can lose that feeling of being a,
an occupant of your body,
like not being identical to your body.
But being sort of just behind your face as a subject who's appropriating
experience in each moment and who's,
you know,
in addition to thoughts arising,
it's felt that there's a thinker of the thoughts,
right?
That's an illusion that can be cut through.
And when you do cut through it,
your experience changes in ways that,
that again,
link up with some of the ideals of,
you know,
traditional contemplative and spiritual and mystical,
uh,
claims.
But again,
you can do that.
We can have a 21st century's science-based conversation about that.
And that's,
that's what I think is worth paying attention to.
All right.
So before we dive into some of the specifics with Jordan,
do you have,
do you ever get shit from the atheist community for even going this far into
spirituality?
Is that,
is that a common thing?
Cause that,
that world of it,
I think I've completely missed.
If so.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I've often joked about the fact that the talk I gave at the,
uh,
the atheist alliance conference in,
I think it was 2007 was the only talk I'm aware of that ever started with a
standing ovation.
And it was booze and people leaving.
And it was this,
I made two points there that,
that people found indigestible.
One,
as I said,
we don't need this word,
atheists or atheism and,
and we don't need to be,
we don't meet,
need to be a victim group that meets and bad hotels and talks about,
you know,
our identity.
Right.
And,
and,
um,
so,
and it was just,
it was just a fact that I had never,
it was just an accident,
but interesting.
True that the book that got me inducted into the,
the,
you know,
the Pantheon of,
of,
of atheists in this generation.
Uh,
the end of faith was a book where I never use the word atheist.
I never thought I'd never suppressed the word atheist.
It just never occurred to me to use it.
I wasn't thinking in terms of atheists and I was thinking in terms of science
and common sense and evidence and you know,
the,
uh,
the obvious,
the for the flight,
flagrant violations of all that on the religious side of the conversation.
So I was,
um,
I don't think we,
we need the word,
I mean,
you know,
we can,
this is a debatable point politically.
Maybe,
maybe the,
maybe I'm wrong about this and it's useful or at least useful for a time.
But,
um,
I think what,
what was the second thing that you said in that?
And then,
so,
so then I followed that with a conversation about 20 minutes of my talking about
spirituality and,
and the contemplative experience of the sort I just mentioned here.
And I said that it was a problem in the atheist community that basically this
variable of atheism and,
and a,
a repudiation of religion was selecting for people who,
for the most part,
either hadn't had certain kinds of experiences or,
or viewed them as,
as just purely pathological.
Like,
these were people who,
you know,
hadn't done psychedelics or came away thinking,
well,
that was just madness.
Or that was,
you know,
those are just drug experiences.
And just that it has some deflationary accountable that,
that,
uh,
basically said,
there's no there,
there,
you know,
there's nothing sacred.
We're just,
you know,
we're just bags of,
of chemicals and we're going to die and then nothing,
and then nothing happens thereafter.
Uh,
and it matters that you have people who don't have a real powers of
introspection.
So it's a notice notice that there's something profound to be gleaned by paying
attention to your experience.
And I used to be one of those people.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I've said that,
but for Psychedelics,
I think,
you know,
if you had,
if you had taught me to meditate when I was 18,
I think I,
I was,
uh,
I again,
I didn't think of myself as an atheist.
I didn't think in those categories,
but I was at,
I was a strident atheists.
And when I would meet someone,
I remember meeting someone and remember when they taught
it was in the,
in the great books seminar in as a freshman in college.
And the Bible was one of the great books.
And I remember just,
you know,
vilifying the Bible,
to my professor because I cause it just like,
what is this theocratic and sanity we're having to read here?
Like,
like,
shoot,
this is,
this is not nearly as good as the other stuff you're having us read.
And I'm meeting half the class that believes this stuff is not just a book.
Right.
It's like I was so,
it's funny to look back on that because I was like,
you know,
I was as militant and atheist as I ever was as a professional atheist and I
didn't even have the category of atheism in my head.
Right.
Uh,
but then I,
you know,
took MDM for the first time and took acid after that and discovered a range of
experience that I was just fundamentally blind to just cognitively,
emotionally,
and every other,
you know,
channel,
like this was a total revelation to me that it was possible to,
to have consciousness appear that way.
Right.
And have,
you know,
when you're,
when you're doing Mtma or when people are take,
you haven't done io,
Lasker,
right?
No.
Right.
Or when people would do all of these things,
how do you know where it,
where it's just something that you need inside you versus true or I guess that
you would count that as,
as true consciousness or true truth.
So whatever is true as a matter of reality out there,
one thing that can't be doubted is that you take one of these drugs and it
proves to you that it's possible to have a different kind of experience.
It could be psychosis,
right?
But like,
it's still instructive to realize that you,
you're having a,
you're tending to get up every morning and be very recognizable to yourself.
I mean,
you are very much like you were yesterday and you're,
and you're beat.
You're being buffeted within the bounds of,
uh,
you know,
positive and negative experience that is very familiar to you.
And at,
you know,
if you were at all like me at that,
at that point in my life,
there was absolutely nothing within that channel that was fundamentally
surprising in a way that would,
would,
uh,
answer to the name of spirituality or,
or anything for you like this.
There's nothing if,
if I,
if you had taken me into the religious section of the bookstore,
the,
or the mystical section of a bookstore,
I would read all of that and
it would be evocative of nothing for me.
It's like,
it's just like there's just these people that you're either conscious frauds or
they're suffering from some kind of psychopathology.
Right?
And that is what many atheists believe about somebody like Jesus or the Buddha
like this.
He's probably an epileptic,
right?
Um,
and we know that the temporal lobe epilepsy can give you,
you know,
or you know,
Migraine Auras can make you think you're having visions,
right?
So,
um,
this is the kind of thing you get from,
you know,
the James Randy's or the world,
right?
And I mean,
and it's no deep knock on James Randy.
I think he's done very important things for the skeptical community and to deep
bunk religious bullshit,
which again I think is dangerous and divisive and confusing and leads people to
waste a lot of time.
I mean it's just so you don't think that that line of thinking though the,
the James Randy line,
I think he just leaves you with enough of a,
of a human experience.
Is that a fair way to somebody else of a,
of a full experience as,
yeah,
you will.
It's just that there is,
there is something absolutely profound and even self transcending about what we
are subjectively.
I mean that's just the consciousness is consciousness is the only thing that
matters on some level.
It's the only space in which anything can matter.
It's the space in which values can be discovered.
It's the,
it's the,
the space in which we discover just how good or bad the universe can be.
Right?
I mean this,
this is the opportunity.
Everything else is just a thought.
Everything else is your memory of yesterday or your expectation of some future
moment where you are going to be conscious,
right?
So you're,
you're always,
ever here in this space where the lights are on and if you went,
when the lights go off,
if you,
you know,
you lose consciousness and anesthesia or death or,
or deep sleep.
Although I think that the jury is still out on whether deep sleep is a,
is a state of unconsciousness,
uh,
you know,
then,
then there's just the absence of,
of all of that.
But here,
as a matter of you're your own subjectivity,
there is just this space and this is the space in which every mystic,
uh,
every founder of a religion,
every,
you know,
every person who's ever had his mind blown on psychedelics or an IOU on Iowasca
or every Shawman,
every like this is the space in which
epiphany's are had and claims true or false about the nature of reality are
made.
And the thing that has been overlooked to,
uh,
to an astonishing degree in the western tradition in particular,
is that,
is that introspection can be a methodology that is,
that,
that can be engaged with real intellectual honesty and a spirit of,
you know,
empirical,
first person,
empirical experiment,
uh,
it can now be correlated with third person methods of studying people's brains
while they have these kinds of insights.
But introspection was just still born in the west 150 years ago.
When,
you know,
people like William James,
we're trying to get it off the ground and what you have in place of a really
intelligent conversation about the nature of human consciousness,
you have people's lingering attachment to Judeo Christian religion in the West,
right?
Apart from what has been imported from something like Buddhism into science now,
I mean,
you have,
you know,
there's dozens of neuroscience labs now that study meditation and there,
a lot of the scientists are essentially closet Buddhists.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and this is,
this will,
this will be,
I'm sure if something Jordan and I disagree about,
or at least this'll,
this'll be a part of the conversation we need to have is that so much of what he
thinks is,
is profound and non negotiable and just,
just,
just ENR,
our bones based on our appearance in the West,
just necessary this Judeo Christian mishegoss he's got going on.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it's just not,
I mean it's just,
it actually isn't,
it's not doing,
it's not doing the necessary work he claims it is.
And even if it's war,
and again,
I'm not denying that you can't have certain experiences that seem meaningful
given that frame.
I mean there's,
you know,
before Jordan was doing this,
you had Joseph Campbell and the whole,
you know,
men's movement,
they had Robert Bly and you know,
other,
other people who were,
who were absolutely entranced by the power of story and you know,
all of the,
the,
the history,
you know,
cross culturally of,
powerful stories being told and just how lives can be framed by story.
Yes.
That is part of,
you know,
possible range of human experience,
but there's something deeper than that and there's something that doesn't entail
any
parochial religious attachment and [inaudible] and so yeah,
I mean
I'm much more focused on that level.
All right,
so I,
I do want us,
since I've been spent so much time around Jordan,
I do want to kind of share some of my thoughts on that specifically,
but just to go back a few minutes,
I've had a few moments on the show when I found that if,
I think if someone's really telling the truth that you were like truly,
truly locked in and in the moment that I do feel something,
I can't quite explain it.
I'm sure I am.
Perhaps you've had experiences like this when you're really having a profound
moment with someone that there is a little bit of an aura,
like a little bit of something that's a little bit different.
And actually I actually had it in that moment that you were talking about that a
few months ago.
It's a fleeting,
it's just a bizarre,
fleeting thing that I can't quite explain,
but I've had it a few times and it's only happened when I felt that someone that
we were either really locked in at that level or I thought someone was truly
being as authentic as they possibly could be.
So as that was just happening just then,
what I really felt you were saying was
be present.
I mean almost everything that you just said really was if we were all sort of
truly being present at the highest level that we could be,
which is virtually impossible to do for more than a fleeting second.
And that's say you talk about that a lot of waking up,
but that's how we would achieve,
I think what you're looking for.
Is that a,
a fair estimation?
Yeah.
Well,
so I mean it's hard to do,
but it's not,
it's actually simple.
It's not complicated.
And so in this circumstance,
so you and I are having a conversation.
We're looking into each other's eyes.
This is a,
this is a experience that we all have all the time or meeting people.
Having these social encounters is so much of what makes us human and it's so
much of what makes the sense of self and their sense of self and other are
inextricably bound up.
And I,
I,
you know,
I would argue that they arise.
It's kind of kind of just really two sides of a single coin.
And so in a moment like this,
it's kind of two levels at which one could be mindful to use the,
the term of jargon that's now everywhere.
I mean,
mindfulness is just an ability to pay close attention to what it's like to be
you without grasping at what's pleasant or pushing away what's unpleasant and
without being lost in thought about it without,
without seeing every moment through this veil of thought.
So,
so you and I,
so the conventional circumstances,
you and I are having a conversation.
We're looking at one another and yet
we're both,
we're both inundated by are the automaticity of our own discursive thought.
So you're talking,
I'm trying to listen to what you're saying,
but I'm being distracted by my own thinking.
Right?
So you say something and I think,
oh go,
wait,
I'm going to say,
what am I going to say to that?
You know?
And so that that contest between the contents of my own mind and just giving you
my attention,
that's something that people are living with all the time.
And they,
if they're not meditators,
they only notice it when things are just,
when it just things run completely off the rails.
So you're reading a book and you realize,
okay,
I've read this page three times and I still don't know what's on the page.
Or like I've just gone down.
It's like,
so then you're just,
you're just a malfunctioning robot at that point.
Like you're just here thinking so much that you can't pay attention to what you
know you want to pay attention to.
And what we have that interpersonal.
So the first,
how real game would be to be someone who in a circumstance like this can just
notice the difference between being lost in thought.
Really just being focused on the other person,
then who's paying attention and to sort of secure that in a,
in a,
uh,
a more frequent way by just get letting go of your thoughts and coming back and
paying attention.
Right.
But oddly thinking about that actually reinforces it in a weird way,
which is part of the say the first problem.
It's not a matter of thinking about it better matter of just just kind of
granting your attention again and like there's nothing to hold on to the moment
you notice you're thinking,
you just come back to,
to paying attention.
Uh,
but the,
the further insight,
which tends to only come once you're,
you get pretty good at the first kind of mindfulness is to notice that this
feeling of being a self over here,
a feeling of being behind your face.
You know,
I mean,
so the feeling that you have that I'm looking at you right,
the feeling that I'm looking at something,
the feeling that you are there to be looked at,
the feeling that you are an object in the world for me.
That if you look for that,
if you look for yourself in this moment,
you can fail to find it in a way that really does change your experience.
Like at like the sense of of being a self,
the sense of being the center of consciousness can drop out in a way that just
just leaves the world.
It justly and it,
it leaves me in the world,
but it leaves me.
It's like lately there's only one face.
You see at this moment you don't see your face.
You just see mine and then obviously I'm in the opposite situation,
but when I'm paying attention to you,
when I'm really paying attention to you,
I lose the sense that I'm over here paying attention to you.
I mean there really is just the world and you are part of it and that,
I mean that's the insight that's often described as as emptiness or or the or
selflessness in in a Buddhist context.
And you can have that.
Obviously you don't have that in,
you don't need another person to have that.
You can have that looking at a coffee cup a or even with your eyes closed but
with another person it's really vivid because so much or so much of our sense of
of being a self as ramified by being in relationship and I I care what you think
of me or like you,
you make a facial expression and I'm react like what does that mean for like how
do you see me?
It's like we're constantly doing this dance with one another where we're reading
in the other person's phase how we're doing and that you know that's something
that you can have the experience of just dropping that entirely and it's,
it's amazingly frame to drop that entirely because you know all of your
psychological suffering and all of your sense of being imperiled in relationship
to other people is is anchored to the sense of I'm me over here are vulnerable
to the thoughts and whims and and and malicious behavior of others and it's
possible to just cancel that if by by paying close enough attention to what is
what consciousness is like.
The thing is that consciousness
consciousness doesn't feel like a self with the feeling of self is is that yet
another object in consciousness?
It's a c is something,
I mean this is again this is I'm,
I'm,
I'm not making a claim about the physics of things.
I'm not,
this is not Deepak Chopra saying that the universe is just consciousness or
[inaudible] consciousness was here before the big bang or anything like that.
But the sense,
and I'm not making any claim that consciousness isn't the product of brains,
but subjectively speaking,
your sense that consciousness is in your head is mistaken.
You head is in consciousness.
You're the feeling of having a head,
the feeling of having a phase.
All of that is,
is appearing in consciousness in this moment.
It's just as much in consciousness as your thoughts are as the,
the,
the world is as sounds are.
I mean so,
so like the feeling that you're inside of something is subjectively has things
backwards.
You can,
you can feel vividly that every,
that everything you experienced in each moment is just a matter of consciousness
and its contents.
And the more you keep dropping back into that position of just being the space
in which everything is arising,
then you can notice that it doesn't actually feel like what you take yourself to
be in most moments,
which is this,
this feeling of,
of being in a cell for being,
uh,
a subject in a riding around in the,
in the middle of everything appropriate in it.
So I sort of had one of those moments there.
Yeah.
I mean I was trying to do it right then,
that guy already,
I'm trying to do it as a listening.
Well,
no,
you can,
you can try to do it.
I mean you can,
it's not that that's,
it's not that all efforts to do it are doomed.
I mean you can,
you can learn how to look for this thing and,
and then find it in a way that cancels the sense that there was anyone looking
or,
and this,
there are ways to,
there broadly speaking,
there's are two ways to do this that you can,
uh,
and again this is,
this is what meditation is.
There's different styles of meditation but,
but they're really only two ways to do this.
You can either look for the self you think you have in a disciplined enough way
and a clear enough way in a way where you're,
you're,
you're no longer lost in thought and you can actually pay attention to
something.
You have enough concentration to pay attention and you look for yourself and
you've,
and you've in that first moment of looking and you fail to find it in a way that
is,
shows you that there's,
it's not there yet.
Everything else is still here and the world is still here.
The lights are still on.
That's one method.
Another method is to pay close enough attention to anything else.
I mean,
whether it's a sound or your breath or sites or another person,
and recognize that when you're truly paying undistracted attention,
you in that moment of seeing say a Coffee Cup,
there really is just seeing there's not a seer and the things seen,
there's not that,
you know,
I mean that really is what it's like to be continually tiling the world with
concepts.
You're just,
you're just,
you know,
it's a,
it is a kind of undercurrent of thought in each moment that you're identified
with and not noticing.
So if,
so a lot of techniques of meditation or just pain,
such scrupulous attention to an object,
a seeming object that you eventually collapse the distance between subject and
object.
And that's it man.
It's a more conventional approach of,
of mindfulness.
So
I got to tell you,
Sam,
I think that getting off Twitter,
yeah,
sorry,
it was probably the whole thing that like what might really be in there.
All right,
so let,
let's talk about a little bit of the specifics of the Jordan because obviously
we've done about 20 of these shows together.
I can tell you've been,
you've been on a major tour with him were,
you know,
I came home now if we're just like two or three days and then,
and then we head out again.
Um,
you know,
I think you know,
that I come more from a position of,
of a lack of belief that a position of belief is sort of where I inherently
start.
Probably similar to the way you described yourself at 18
from every,
now he's different every night.
Every night that we've done one of these,
he,
you know,
I open it up and makes people laugh.
He does about an hour and a half every single night.
It's been different.
So some nights he's talking about the fate of the West.
Some nights he talks about the sovereignty of the individual.
So I'm 19 gives you the 12 rules that are in the book it cemetery.
He mixes it up every night.
But at some point there always something that whittles down to something about
truth and belief of course
from what I can,
I don't want to,
as Eric would say,
if we're going to do this,
we should as Eric Wise,
I would say if we're going to do this,
we should probably try to steal man him properly and maybe he'll watch this and
I told them that we were going to do this.
So you know,
hopefully it offers a little something for both of you guys.
I never see him pushing the straight up idea of religion on people.
Now he is doing,
he's doing it through the prism that you described,
the sort of Judeo Christian prism of things where he's talking about these
stories and what I sensed that he's really hitting on that is resonating with
people and it does resonate with me even is that the power of these stories,
and maybe this is sort of the Joseph Campbell thing,
the power of these stories does offer some other transcendent truth that you
cannot get another way.
So the way that I can give it to you in a way that sort of makes sense to me,
to me is that,
you know,
although I didn't really like the last couple movies,
that the amount that I've loved star wars in my life,
the way that the stories of star wars,
right,
that they,
those stories of star wars have more relevance to what,
how I sort of view good and evil and,
and,
um,
the journey that you're on as a person.
Um,
they have more value to me than anything that I ever read out of biblical
things.
So I'm not taking his biblical version of it,
but that the power of story can somehow offer you some other,
some map to truth that I don't think necessarily is in conflict with anything
you've said.
Does that,
no,
I'm not,
I'm not giving you poorly what his argument is.
I'm just giving you sort of my personal take.
Yeah.
No,
but I'm,
I'm aware of,
of what he's been saying in this regard and yeah.
And,
um,
and I think this is where maybe you guys got a little lost in that first
conversation that yet.
I mean,
so just as a general matter,
I love much of what he says he's does with some regularity.
Say something ridiculous enough with the same confidence.
He says all the good things that I perceive a real problem with what he's doing.
Me An example of one of those just for,
well,
I mean,
did you see his uh,
event with Matt Dillahunty?
You see that?
I didn't see it,
but I know a lot of people have been taught that's worth watching,
but so,
so,
uh,
and again,
I'm hoping,
my hope is that we can make progress in these conversations where we don't get
stuck just having a knock down drag out over,
over things like the points I'm going to raise now,
but by the way,
real quick for the record,
just,
I'm more than happy to tell you,
like,
he I think is in that same exact spot.
He wants it to be fruitful and friendly and all of those things,
which I think goes back to what we talked about,
you know,
an hour ago about just the way we all relate to each other.
Right?
But I mean,
he'll confidently say things like,
you know,
atheists aren't really atheists.
I mean,
like there's,
I really atheists,
there's a psychopath who murders people.
I mean,
so there are those people have existed,
but someone like Sam Harris or Richard Dawkins,
or maybe you said this directly to Matt Dillahunty in this case,
uh,
they're not,
they only think they're atheist,
not really atheist.
They have a god and that's functioning in their life and then just not
acknowledging it.
Right.
Um,
you know,
there,
and again,
it comes back,
it comes back to this historical claim that we all grew up in the west.
We're all,
we all just got our ethics and our,
our theology without ever naming it.
We got it in the water.
Right.
And,
um,
so any sense you have of what is good and worth doing?
Uh,
any sense you have a value?
Just the reason why it would be bad to murder somebody.
Uh,
the reason why you don't have to think that through from first principles every
day,
uh,
and you,
and you can just navigate the social space with other people in the West.
It's because you are just fundamentally dependent on these stories,
this tradition,
right.
And this,
this God,
and he's very,
you know,
uh,
I don't know what the steel man interpretation of what he's actually doing is
here,
but to my eye,
he's very,
yeah,
they're evasive or,
or a noncommittal about what he means by God.
But he's,
he,
he's,
however he's using the word,
he's not making a clear claim about what he believes.
He'll often say,
oh,
it would take me 40 hours to answer that.
Or I wrote a 600 page book on that and I can't,
if I go like he,
he will,
he will decline to answer a fairly straightforward question about what he
believes about Jesus or about God or so made the buys.
We'll get somewhere around that.
He doesn't,
I don't think,
I think I could probably count on one hand how many times he's actually
mentioned God's specifically in the,
in the course of all this cause he likes the stories and the Matt and what he
would say are the maps of meaning I think are much more important to him than
the,
to agree on the exact definition of God.
But the,
but the claim for instance,
that I am in a way that I fundamentally don't understand,
but he does that I am captive of the Judeo Christian tradition right there.
My ethics is born of it and that my notion of ultimate value is somehow anchored
to Jesus.
Right.
Uh,
I mean that is just so preposterous as to be unarguable.
Right.
This is Shania Shapiro would take a similar argument just not related to gt
Jesus though he,
I think he would say something similar.
Right?
Because I,
because my mother was Jewish,
presumably he would think I'm,
you know,
Jewish rather than Judeo Christian or that he would say that your enlightenment
values.
I mean,
I think when I've done this with him,
because we'd say if I say,
well,
all the goodness in me,
the things that I believe in,
the moral principles that I believe in are really enlightened about as he would
say,
well,
you really have to dial it back to where else not proving the point.
He thinks he's proven with it.
Right.
So it's,
um,
but these are the,
I mean these are like points of confusion.
Yeah.
I think we could get behind it,
get passing in five minutes,
but it's also possible that he's going to dig in for two hours on this and then
we'll have three more events to do.
And I'm not sure what the hell's going to happen.
So,
um,
but I,
I mean,
I really hope to make progress with him because again,
I think,
uh,
I think what he's doing is very interesting on,
on other fronts and what he is exposed is a real need,
a real hunger for a meaning based conversation about,
you know,
how do you get your life straight in a,
in the 21st century.
Um,
and I mean clearly,
clearly there's a hunger for wisdom that the secular community has not been
answering any kind of reliable way.
And so we want to hear from people who are saying,
well,
you know,
I'm going to,
I've been an atheist,
but you know,
what I'm hearing from Peterson is,
you know,
really causing me to get my life together.
Uh,
that just tells me that it's no surprise.
I've said this about atheism for ever since I was talking about atheism.
Atheism is not a philosophy.
Atheism has nothing.
Atheism is just a denial of the fall certainties of religious people.
It's like,
no,
there's no,
there's no good reason to believe in Poseidon.
And there's no good reason to believe in Yahweh.
That's atheism,
right?
So atheism doesn't give you anything that makes you live a meaningful life and
that's not,
but the thing is Contra Peterson,
that's not a knock on atheism.
That's all the atheism.
Atheism is just not being convinced by the,
the bad religion,
the bad evidence and arguments put forward by religious people.
It leaves just a space for better conversations that you may or may not have.
You may or may not discover,
you may or may not fall in love with science and,
and a rational approach to,
to the contemplative life in a weird way as someone that wants to connect
atheism to spirituality.
The failure of whatever the atheist movement before you was,
you know,
weird ways is kind of good because you want to lead atheism to a future,
right?
Like I'm completely unconcerned by atheism.
I'm,
I'm concerned about the future.
Right?
It's like,
you know,
but the,
again,
the place where Peterson and I will,
we'll have disagreed and we'll disagree is,
I mean I think he,
I don't think he understands atheism or I've never heard him say anything that
that is an accurate portrayal of what it's like to be,
you know,
this sort of atheist or certainly many atheists.
I know,
um,
sort of reframing your experience.
Yes.
You,
but the truth is you can do that with stories that you know,
to be bullshit.
Like you,
you can do that with Batman.
While I'm telling you,
I mean,
I know star wars is a true story.
Nobody it has no,
but may be,
but you could decide like,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get up each morning and think of myself as Luke Skywalker.
Like,
you know,
you're not Luke Skywalker.
Well,
you know,
Luke Sky Walker was invented by someone who in your lifetime,
right?
So there's no,
so deep thing going back to our DNA,
right.
This is just the Luke Skywalker and you can do it.
And,
and perhaps,
you know,
perhaps Jordan would want to say,
well,
no,
it looks Skywalker does go back to the DNA because Joseph Campbell was really in
touch with these ancient myths and it was Joseph Campbell who gave George Lucas
all of his story's structure.
Okay.
Leave it aside.
You could do it with that.
You pick the most preposterous character you want.
They could still conceivably be inspiring Spiderman,
right?
Um,
you could get up tomorrow and say,
I'm,
you know,
I'm just going to view each situation of the day that I encounter through the
lens of what would spider man do you know,
what,
how would Spiderman Act here?
How I'm walking into a Starbucks,
right?
I feel sort of vaguely neurotic,
I'm gonna about to meet the Barista and I'm like,
you know,
having trouble making eye contact,
right?
I'm,
I'm that I'm the same neurotic person I was yesterday,
but how would Spiderman do this,
right?
Like,
and how would,
how would,
if I knew that I could just take down everyone in this place if I wanted to and
I can use,
shoot a web and fly over a building,
right?
If I knew that about myself,
how would I navigate each subsequent moment here?
That the truth,
the truth of the matter is that changes your psychology.
You can do it with total fictitious bullshit,
right?
It's a trick.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a mind hack,
right?
That's the same game,
It doesn't require,
and,
and it doesn't require young to be right about the collective unconscious.
Now you could say,
well,
it only works if there really is something that the,
you know,
the substrate layer that is ancient and,
and spooky,
um,
that,
that's an empirical claim that,
you know,
may be on falsifiable or,
or maybe worth debating.
But the reality is,
is that stories have power.
Even if you,
you and some stories have more power than others,
right?
And we can talk about,
you know,
how,
why,
what makes a certain story more compelling or structured in a way that that's
more compelling.
But the reality is that the mind is,
is plastic to a remarkable degree and are our persistence in having the same
mediocre,
mediocre experience we had yesterday.
Is,
is a kind of habit and you can create other habits that are more inspiring and
more more useful.
And yes,
it is totally possible to use some traditional framework to do that.
Or some weird cultic framework.
I mean,
someone can invent a new,
you know,
a new operating system and you know,
and call it Scientology or call it whatever,
and uh,
gather acolytes under that,
in that context.
And even the,
and this is how weird our circumstances,
you can have a,
a malicious fraud doing that.
And someone like l Ron Hubbard,
who was clearly a con man,
right?
Uh,
and people can derive genuine benefit from it.
It's not like every Scientologists as wrong about the benefit they got from
Scientology.
It's clearly they're not right.
It wouldn't,
wouldn't persist to the degree that it has if everyone's just having a bad time
and seeing no benefit ever.
Right.
It's not,
it's not co would be over in a day.
Well,
they're sweating,
load all that.
Yeah,
that's right.
Whenever they're doing in the sauna.
So.
All right.
So then that,
I think maybe we can wrap it with that cause I don't want to,
I'm not here to litigate obviously on,
on behalf of door.
And I thought if you could just get some of these ideas,
we'll,
I'm sure we'll get into house.
What's the date of the first one?
Um,
you would,
people would have to check my website.
July.
Or is it,
no,
the first one,
it's the end of this month in Vancouver.
We've got two shows like the 23rd and fourth I think.
Yeah.
And then we've got Dublin and London in July,
middle of July 14th I think.
Is Dublin in the 16th as London could have.
It could be a day off there.
Well I have him back in here on the 29th so that'll be right in between the two.
So maybe that'll be an interesting spot to them.
Yeah.
All right.
So then my final thing on this and then we can wrap would be,
so what
does it matter at the end of the day?
Let's say,
let's say everything you've said here is,
and,
and
a certain amount of people watching this can can start going down that road and
finding truth that allows them to live as presently and honestly and,
and fulfillingly as possible.
And let's say for the amount of people that are showing up to Jordan's events,
they hear what he's saying and feel that it allows them to do that exact same
thing.
Whether you believe that that skimming off the top are not fully actualizing
open,
but they ultimately live a good life.
That is,
you know,
that the life that's coming from what you're prescribing to what Jordan's
prescribing ultimately both become comparably moral,
decent,
good lives at the end of the day then does it matter?
Well,
I think having a coherent idea about truth matters.
And so this is a sticking point that Jordan and I hit in our first podcast and
uh,
I see it operating in a lot of what he's saying.
And so that,
that I think should be ironed out and I think it can be ironed out and you can
still be totally enamored of the usefulness of myth where like you can still
like almost nothing else shifts in what he's doing.
And you can still acknowledge that there's a difference between this is what,
what Bret Weinstein I think usefully dubbed metaphorical truth and the literal
truth.
And it's only by the light of literal truth that you can even make that
distinction,
right?
Like,
like clearly we need those two categories and we need to be able to say that
certain things are not literally true,
but they're useful,
right?
And certain things are,
uh,
to starkly false.
So I mean,
they don't even have to have no truth to them.
I mean,
someone could just be miss fundamentally mistaken about reality and that could
be,
there are certain circumstances or under what circumstances under which that
could be useful,
right?
So it's like,
like,
like to make those distinctions is the only way to preserve a notion of truth
that gets you something like a legitimate science and legitimate error
correcting mechanism where it really matters that your beliefs both be
internally consistent,
your belief system internally consistent and map onto reality in some way that
is,
uh,
you know,
if they were false,
you'd be unlikely to believe what you believe.
I mean that.
But the problem is what people are getting and this is,
you know,
traditionally what religion has been and what,
what dogmatism always gives you.
I mean,
dogmatism is the state of no longer interacting with reality in a way that
would,
that would error correct your beliefs.
Like I'm going to believe this thing that I believed yesterday.
No matter what you tell me,
no matter what you show me,
no matter what happens in human history,
Jesus is the son of God,
right?
Whatever,
whatever it is,
right?
Uh,
that's,
that's religion.
It traditionally speaking.
And that is precisely the state in which the human mind and human communities
can't error correct and make intellectual progress.
So clearly that's not,
that part is not worth preserving.
Uh,
and to some degree I perceive Jordan is trying to have it both ways and uh,
he'll,
he'll be,
he'll endorse science in,
in,
you know,
various ways,
but he will also endorse,
and he won't call it dogmatism,
but I'm perceiving it to be dogmatism into them.
And that's something that I certainly hope that we can flesh out and converge
on.
So it's good that you guys are doing for these because each one is going to sort
of be like a discovery session until yeah.
Until you can get enough of an agreement on that sort of base level stuff and,
and yeah,
you may end up just lost in the weeds on it,
but we have,
we,
unlike my podcast,
we have a moderator really in all four times.
Doug Douglas is doing something with Bret Weinstein's going to is actually a
moderator for Vancouver.
So he knows his job and,
and I think he'll be great at it.
Uh,
Douglas Murray is joining us in London and Dublin and he is not a moderator,
but I think just,
just having Douglas there will keep us from,
from missing each other.
Totally.
I mean they'd Douglas Bro,
smart,
very calming effect on all this.
Uh,
all right,
well I don't think we should go two years again before we go,
before we do this again and we have it,
we should also say we have a conference coming up in,
in New York in November,
which you are our m scene.
And,
um,
this is actually,
this is,
this is very cool.
Could have an idea.
You've been bouncing around for awhile.
Yeah.
Why don't you tell her this is a,
rather than avoid controversial topics for this,
this conference,
we decided to just,
just rams toward the most provocative.
And so we have a session on me too.
I think it's titled,
it has me to gone too far and it's going to be a panel of,
uh,
women,
all women journalists.
I think that's true to say.
Uh,
and fantastic people like Masha Gessen and a very wise and,
uh,
Katie Roiphe.
Um,
Rebecca Traister I don't think can make it,
but the,
we're still building it out,
but it's,
it will be the full spectrum of yes.
Has Gone too far to,
hasn't gone far enough.
It'll,
it should be a very interesting conversation.
Uh,
there's a panel on race with Glen Lowery who,
you know is fantastic and I'm pretty sure we're Tanahashi coats is going to do
it.
And so Tom House,
he is just as far to the,
to the,
the,
uh,
extreme racial side of this as a possible.
So you just wanted to thrust me in the middle of this thing and see what
happens.
Um,
and we always wish all have to talk about how that stuff gets moderated.
But um,
and then it's got a,
Coleman used this,
this,
a young crazy on undergraduate who's writing these,
these pieces in Colette,
uh,
to give you a sense of just how weird the the left is.
So,
so Coleman,
he has written these,
these pieces on race and Colette,
he's this African American undergraduate at Columbia writing these essays that,
that so many of us have found,
uh,
just,
just one incredibly well written,
right.
I mean,
just,
he does not have any of the,
the affectations of someone who's overriding and those age,
which is just amazingly rare.
Yeah.
And just so clear headed,
right.
And,
uh,
so I retweeted one of his essays saying like,
congratulations,
Coleman and I just decided to check my app mentions justice,
just not just to take the temperature of the situation.
And this is more evidence of my racism that I'm,
that I'm favorably re-tweeting if like this,
this uncle Tom,
as you'd expect.
Uh,
so,
uh,
it's amazing.
But anyway,
that again will be a panel that spans the full range of opinion on,
on these topics,
on this topic of race.
And the question is,
can we get beyond race?
And then there's a panel on Islam that we'll have,
uh,
Majid and I on who,
you know,
are all stars on the,
I would argue the perfectly sane side of this conversation,
but it will also have Fareed Zakaria and,
and Shadi Hamid who,
you know,
I view it as the kind of intervention on those guys because like you to my ear,
they've just been making the wrong noises on this.
And I did,
I've done the podcast with both of them,
but me being a white guy,
non Muslim,
you know,
who didn't grow up in the culture,
uh,
there's,
there's certain moves not opened to me for,
you know,
the kind of audience that will be persuaded by someone.
Like Fareed are shoddy,
saying you don't understand the Muslim experience or whatever it is.
So obviously they can't do that.
Talking to [inaudible] and Majid,
um,
or Sarah Haider.
And so all of those people will be on the panel and that should be fascinating.
Uh,
and then finally there's a panel that Fareed is actually going to go to
moderate,
which is a [inaudible] truth is,
I'm on it.
I don't know who else is gonna be on,
I think is going to be Eric Weinstein and Bret Weinstein and a few other people,
and it'll just be talking about rationality and know his reason sacred as the
title of that panel.
And you're doing a meditation session.
Oh yeah.
I think I'm going to do a meditation workshop in that,
so it's like a 10 hour day,
but uh,
it shouldn't get to be good after all this moderation.
I'm going to need a little [inaudible] to come by for that and said her for that
one.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
it's always a pleasure my friend.
Don't follow him on Twitter because I won't be getting there,
but you can check out the waking up podcast@samharris.org.